do do do so you were asking
yeah by the time i came around mitzi
shore
was already uh in an advanced
stage and uh she was older okay and she
had some health issues
and so she wasn't banging comics at that
point but there was a time
there's a time when she was getting she
was the boss
she was the boss woman and she would
grab comedians
and jimmy schubert talked about he was
like 21 years old wanted to be a comic
all sudden he's banging mincy shore like
yikes do we know anybody
famous famous i don't know i don't know
who's talking about it i know jimmy
talked about it
in robin williams argus talked about it
i have no idea
but it's in it's a part of the reason
why i'm saying it is because it's part
of the comedy store documentary that
they're putting out i mean she is a
joint
she was an animal yeah like she's a
pretty girl she
also was like the most important figure
in comedy outside of comedians
like by running that store that way and
letting all those people just
be buck wild and have this crazy
creative environment
that's where kennison erupted from and
that's where you know richard pryor used
to work out there
and bill hicks started there and so many
people so many people were there
in their early days why do you think
that it could flourish that way
because of her but like how did she make
money
like did she have money how did it well
there was a lot of great comedy
right so you got to think you've got
richard pryor there
you've got david letterman there you've
got tim thomas i mean there was a
giant cast of great comedy
that came out of that club and it was a
cultural landmark and still is a
cultural landmark in hollywood
so there's money to be made there yeah
and there was that was the roaring days
of the 80s where it was packed all the
time and then there was like a drop off
but now it's when we get to open again
it'll be packed again
yeah it's like before the the pandemic
it was probably the best it's ever been
doing
yeah i mean i would go in there and it
was insane
all three rooms packed i mean just
comics everywhere
the vibe was right it's a real shame
yeah it is a real shame but it's just
one part of the real shame of all this
craziness that's been going on for the
last few months
yeah you know it's uh and now we're just
talking about it before
like there's all these articles now
about how doctors are saying that the
people coming to them are less sick than
they ever were before
yeah there's like in in or in um italy
rather
they're saying there's such a small
amount of virus it's almost undetectable
yeah it's run through the country yeah
it's hot out yeah you think that's all
it was so trump was right
trump said it was going to go away
without any cure well and then it did
it would but it would have killed more
people yeah i don't know how many more
people though
i don't know if there could have been a
better strategy i don't know dude the
problem is we're monday monday
morning uh quarterbacking yeah it's like
after the fact we're going oh this is
what we should have done and we're not
talking about gonna die
yeah i didn't think we were gonna die
but like
i thought it could have gotten kind of
bad a little bit i made a few phone
calls of friends i was like you know go
stock your fridges we might be in the
crib for a little bit but the only thing
that helped me was idris elba why would
he say because he got it he was fine
yeah i was like look at it yeah do you
think they really got it
yes i do like you you don't think it's
weird that like the second it pops off
tom hanks is like i got it
well the whole crew got it a lot of
people were hospitalized it was in
australia
it was a break out in that area okay
yeah it was cause that's what i would do
if i wanted people to be afraid right
i'd be like who's the most famous guy
he got it oh you're going deep
conspiracy i'm just saying wouldn't you
do that i even smoked any weed yet
are we maybe at the end but once i smoke
it's over
i just want you know what happens it's
just
i'll fall apart i'll like start doing
like i'll start like doing like beat
boxing maybe it just gets really bad
if it gets horrible if we wanted to
point to a conspiracy
yeah that you i would say you would kill
tom hanks i wouldn't say you let him
walk away
free because he gets it and he
kicks because then yeah i'm not scared
if tom hankson kick it
yeah tom asking kicking i can kick it
for sure yeah yeah that's true yeah it
was interesting like
it was like uh only famous people got it
initially
you know what i mean it was like this is
what i heard of yeah but it was like the
new blue check that's what we were
calling it because like
i i remember i didn't know a single
regular person that had it
but all these athletes had it every
basketball team a few people had it
all these actors had it yeah i was just
like how the [ __ ] are they getting it
see that the act the athlete thing was
like okay well these are super athletes
and they don't have
any any form you know what it was what
they were flying [ __ ] in bro oh
you know what it was dear you come on
dare you come on dude i feel like it was
just using the wrong
fountain those days are done
we could all use any fountain now okay
cut the clip send it to cnn with a
[Laughter]
let's talk about them let's talk about
them i feel like um the athlete
thing was like okay they're super
athletes and they don't have any
symptoms
right but we're not super athletes okay
yeah but then idris elba is just a
really good
in-shape actor yeah well he seems okay
tom hanks is an older gentleman
who doesn't look like he's in great
shape yeah and he got through it yeah
what is you know and then you find out
the flu numbers and the but it's not the
flu okay
okay it's not the flu yeah okay it's not
the flu yeah you know
science is a new religion bro well think
about it
think about it though no if it's monday
monday i think i really believe this i
really
know what you're saying with the monday
morning but like quarterbacking think
about like the way religion
operated in the past right the second
you said anything against the church
they shame you they ostracize you who
the [ __ ] are you
how could you say these things they put
you in your little box over there you
get excommunicated
any of us who are like you sure it
really kills everyone right
like are you sure are you sure it's that
contagious what the [ __ ] is
fauci come out of the keebler elf house
tell them what's going on
they just rail at you non-stop yeah and
the second
and the second you say a single thing
you were what did they label you as i
think amazon even like took down a book
a heretic right wasn't it is that what
the term is
i think you were blasphemy or something
one of these
things right and then all of a sudden
this
information starts to come out where
it's like okay it's not that bad the
curve is kind of flattening
now the [ __ ] comes out today that was it
basically said if you're asymptomatic
you can't transfer it as easily as they
thought it's almost impossible right so
all that worry that we wear about kids
giving it to their grandmothers they're
not going to do that was the only reason
why
stores are shut down the only reason why
comedy club shut down restaurants
because if you're asymptomatic you pass
on now we know you're not if you have a
cough
if you're sneezing if you've got the flu
stay the [ __ ] home that's it crank it
open let's go
crank it open yeah isn't it meanwhile
you have to wait massive no new jersey
just said they want another month
for so this is where we get into like
the i'm on my mind
but you don't think this is just people
trying to get reelected um
it could be but it could be people who
are scared of people dying on their
watch
because now it's not the economy to get
to reelected it's people dying on your
watch
well if someone comes along and says the
reason why x amount of people died it
could have been much less if you had
just
done the right thing and kept those
people safe and kept everything closed
for another month right so i think it's
that it's also
a lot of these people are not healthy
people right i know a lot of really
intelligent people that are not healthy
and
terrified of this virus yeah and i would
try to tell them well hey let's look at
the actual statistics
yeah the actual statistics are it
doesn't seem like it's fun to catch
yeah right but as long as you have a
good
level of nutrients in your body you have
a adequate
sufficient levels of vitamin d zinc you
take care of yourself get in the sauna
drink a lot of water
don't get [ __ ] up every night don't
eat sugar all day
like you're probably gonna be okay and
maybe what's devastating
even more so is how many suicides we we
had
how many people died because because of
the depression
yo did you hear that stat that like
corona actually saved lives
because people weren't driving so they
didn't get in car accidents oh that's
true
like in a weird way way less people it
saved car accident deaths car accidents
deaths
what else was there i mean there was a
lot more domestic violence but
a lot more child abuse too really yeah a
lot of child abuse a lot of domestic
violence and then what's really scary is
the [ __ ] suicides because people
who are already barely hanging on but
might have pulled through if they had a
good job yeah
had a way to make a living now they're
broke and they have to beg for money and
they they got one
twelve hundred dollar check everybody i
know
that's a comic is making more money how
all these comics that were like
they're barely they were like middling
on the road they were barely doing it
they get the 1200 stemi check they get
furloughed from their job so i think you
get like 600 bucks or something a month
when a week or something when you're
furloughed they're making like a grand a
week
like everybody had money dude this is
the crazy [ __ ] about anything
the stock market hasn't budged but
that's how you know the stock market's
fake
or this is fake they price out
everything joe
they price out every the super bowl they
price it out they price out the what is
it the other thing we were just in the
pandemic they priced out right
and it dipped down the protest right now
they priced out they priced out the
protest
they're mit mathematicians really i
think
[Laughter]
call up licks friedman let's let's get
to the bottom of this
lex call me buddy i was funny when we
were at the store and i was teasing him
because he was dressed like a men in
black dude and uh and then you'd go he's
a black belt jiu jitsu too and i was
like oh okay
he's a super nerd he's a nerd that can
kill you yeah yeah
nerds like that jujitsu yeah well it's a
very intellectual pursuit believe it or
not it seems like it wouldn't be yeah it
seems like it just brute strength and
[ __ ] like that but it's not
but also they just want to like touch
people like they're just
there's like no socialization could be
like you're just in your cubicle
and then you get to embrace be awkward
yeah yeah
yeah get past the normal awkwardness of
touching people
well and you maybe never were able to
like we need [ __ ] affection like
you go to like like africa right and you
super homophobic a lot of these
countries but the dudes are holding
hands the dudes are hugging each other
kissing each other when they [ __ ]
meet
and i think it's because if you can't
just [ __ ] broads regularly
you need that affection somewhere right
so
you just get it from your boys how come
they can't [ __ ] broads regularly
i think there's not like just dating
cultures like if there's no alcohol it's
harder just like go to the
hookah spot and pick up a product
like where do you even date like if you
can't drink
yeah if you can't go out for a drink
where would you date
where would you meet in your social
circle you have to meet at the mosque
and what are you going to pick up girls
at the mosque you'd have
i bet a lot of it would be like your
girl or
or like like your girl would have a
friend yeah and she would try to
introduce her to jamie
that kind of deal oh yeah you know what
i mean yeah like oh i know this single
guy
i'm gonna set you up there's probably a
lot of that yeah you know what i'm
saying
yeah arranged yeah and there's probably
a lot of like girls trying to sabotage
relationships so that i think might be
so much better with you and they try to
sabotage relationships with their
girlfriend and some guy
so they can sneak in some other dude
whoa
for sure like a terror plot yeah for
sure they do that yeah i just don't
think he's good for you i just don't
debbie you can do so much better i mean
yeah he's fine
how happy are you that you don't have to
date
through all this like how about dean
through the pandemic
uh yeah i didn't get it all i got a girl
so um yeah that would be the worst like
the guys that i know that are the most
depressed right now are single that been
by themselves for two [ __ ] months
you know they're having people come up i
think some of them
don't have that ability oh they but then
they were you know they were not i
wasn't able to say losers
they weren't getting any [ __ ] before
well they were getting some occasionally
but they they had to go out and get it
right right you have to go you have a
couple of drinks with someone yeah next
thing you know
dude i don't even know how to get laid
anymore i'm thinking
i bet you ask you just beg you just
you got to bring a consent form and have
them sign and you have to record it
everyone's going to be a pornographer so
that every step of the way gets
documented
like this is for us we're going to put
it in a vault and a safe deposit box
but just so everybody knows true that
you you
were well aware and wanted to do all
this stuff you can't change
what happened yeah you can't decide
after you feel terrible
yeah like just asking some people do
distort
which the distorting part is what's
really scary like openly distort
like what happened with you and like you
know the chris hardwick story no
go it's a terrible one yeah wait this is
accused of sexual assault and this is
her definition of sexual assault
she said yes to him because he had told
her
that if uh in the past that they had
been in relation
he had been in a relationship in the
past where the girl didn't want sex as
much as him and he didn't like it
so this was her her reasoning
for describing why her saying yes to him
and having sex with him was actually him
sexually assaulting her
yeah it's crazy right so yeah he had all
these text messages from her
yeah he had all these like he documented
everything yeah
luckily but yet people were still
upset that amc hired him back even
though it was shown
that she lied and not him and that none
of it
like he actually broke up with her
because she was making out with some
other guy
like there was a lot of craziness to it
and she cheated on him but it didn't
matter like they were still going after
him
yeah people are still going everything
people can distort
the version of the the the relationship
that you had
mm-hmm and even if you could prove it
wrong
you're still on the wire for the lie a
believer
i always believe women and there's
people that do say that believe all
women believe
you can't believe all anything you can't
believe all cops
you can't believe all doctors yeah i
don't like all arguments it's a dumb
argument outside of stand up
oh yeah well for funny stand up yeah all
arguments are the best
yes sure that's it makes it makes good
comments it's fun
it's fun like plus it also now you got
me thinking about believe all women i'm
like how can i find a way
well you hear burst bit burns like all
of them yeah yeah yeah
everybody knows that's nonsense when you
say something like yeah but they get
behind it it's a weird
i don't know you know what you know what
i mean youtube is always casey anthony
do we believe her what does she say she
killed her [ __ ] kid she killed her
kid and duct taped it and
she covered that trunk uh-huh yeah she
got away with it too
but like how did she do it she murdered
her kid
like with a knife or something like that
no i know she's in florida or something
like that yeah
they found the body but they found blood
and they found a bunch of different
things so the baby disappeared the
baby's gone
exactly she killed the kid it's a famous
story no i know i heard the thing but we
don't know if the baby's dead did we
find the baby
i don't think they ever found it so the
baby's not dead i'd say
that's what i would say i was like
skeletal remains yeah not good um that's
right
wasn't there a situation where after the
fact they found
another web browser that they hadn't
bothered checking on a computer
and it was like how to get rid of the
baby that one was all like you know how
to get rid of a body
yeah how long does it take for a body to
decompose yeah what's the best way to
kill it but this was the case where like
her lawyer she might not search that in
the interest of not getting sued
it might not have been how do you kill a
baby god it sucks that you have to
preface
according to google neck breaking how to
make chloroform
yeah for everybody that watches this
show i just want you know jamie doesn't
have a computer he just knows all this
stuff
put up here put up the the list of these
things and what is the article there's
this i'm looking on the wikipedia for it
that's all etcetera so this is what they
said that she had probably wikipedia it
says i'm brian callan's brother well i
guess this has a
says i have crohn's disease too they're
just making sure do you have it no so
the casey anthony thing her lawyer said
that her dad did it
did you see that that was the defense
her lawyer said her dad
yeah so the defense was hey we just need
to make it plausible that someone else
killed a baby
oh my god and then you got to handle
that [ __ ] yourself they know somebody
killed the baby and then someone was in
the family
but it got her off the point is yeah you
don't i don't think she
i i again say again so the point is i
don't want to be dating anybody right
now this is the thing you can't trust
anybody
yes but here's the thing with her do you
think she killed the baby on purpose or
the baby died and then she's like
[ __ ] i killed a baby how do i get rid of
this thing so it looks like i didn't
kill a baby
that's a good question now we're in the
realm what would you do if you killed a
baby by accident
wow that's heavy it's a tough one
because you didn't mean to
right like you were doing the game you
know where you throw the baby
right and then just into a fan
it didn't have to die
fans is really [ __ ] whizzing around
you forgot yeah okay this is just not
delirious that mentions the doc or the
searches it's from in the middle of the
case it's like a web archive
her mom said that uh
they gave the baby to a babysitter which
nobody could find
and that casey's car smelled like a dead
body
yeah she probably left it in there a
long time you got a sloppy [ __ ] like
that
yeah they don't clean up the baby quick
yeah she said it was from an old pizza
and trash that was in the trunk
not human was she one of these like hot
girls yeah remember there was like a
time where like hot girls were killing a
lot
it was her and then that other girl
right like there were smoke shows just
[ __ ]
joints were killing what was the other
girl she killed someone i think it was
an la trial
which one was this oh god she was like
spanish or something she was like kind
of like
spicy yeah do you remember this no yeah
no i'm interested
it was like a pretty bad murder we
googled like the hottest like chicks who
murdered
oh yeah
because we want to see like you know
like when you're like great at what you
do you can get away with it
yes you know i'm sure people have done
bits about that like you know blah blah
was so great he could get away
michael jackson's so great he could get
away with these things and we were like
does the same thing work for like hot
chicks
who kill like would you still [ __ ] and
if they'd be willing to [ __ ] you yeah oh
no if you yeah if you were gonna do it
yeah
like if a prime time like what's
give me what do you think is the hottest
girl you've ever seen
hottest girl i've ever seen obviously
outside of our of course significant
others joe
100 um just give me an example so like
publicly
joint adriana lima is a
now imagine adriana lima yes she kills
her husband
but i'll clean it up guys i'll clean him
up [ __ ] no no no no no guys a piece
of [ __ ] he could be
the kindest man ever he she could kill
him while he's like feeding
cleft palate kids and i would take the
kid i put them in another room obviously
i wouldn't kill a kid i'd clean up the
guy's dead body
and then we would do whatever trust her
if you were [ __ ] her with a lot of
objects around i would want it to be in
like a basketball court or she you know
[ __ ] her with objects around i won't
i don't listen that's how i'm not
[ __ ] her on the table at the joe
ronin again that's something
there's always knives on this [ __ ]
table that's what i'm thinking someone's
gonna grab a knife and stab you
yeah i don't know right now she comes uh
right through your rib cage like oh my
god i should have listened to joe and
taking her to the gym
i once had oh this was back in my like
bad days you know i'm a good guy now
performed
ho if you will but uh i remember i had a
girl over
and um i remember i left my wallet
in the living room oh no and she went to
like the bathroom or something like to
clean up
and i remember i like went into the
living room i grabbed my wall and like
put in like a pair of pants and then i
sat there saying i'm like
am i [ __ ] girls i think will steal
from me like like
what's happening in my life that i'm
willing to go through with this
well you do though when you're a a young
man and you're horny
that's a drug dealer you got a drug
dealer in front of you yeah it's not
just a girl that you're interested in
you're also you have a real
need yeah well guys are horny i mean i
don't know what it's like
i'm obviously talking just for men
because i don't know what it's like when
a girl's horny maybe it's exactly the
same feeling
i don't think it is i don't i i would
assume that like all other things
men and women are very different so i
think the horny part's very different
too
yeah but when men are horny it gets
desperate it gets
weird like drug addict-y desperate yeah
i think
i've always wondered that with like
women like if because we
always chalk it up to ourselves like if
we get laid right it's like oh i kicked
great game
like that was me like i took that you
know down or whatever you know
and i wonder if a lot of it is like
their emotional state
in the day like like let's say their
their cat went missing or something like
if that
they're like oh [ __ ] i'm really down i'm
gonna go
hook up with this guy because that's
gonna elevate my
emotional state i think for some girls i
think some girls just want to escape and
they'll just go have a
you know just a fling right
but see i think with girls they have to
worry about men
in a dangerous way where men don't
really have to worry about girls the
same way
yeah there's a dude you know what it is
like you saw obviously you saw the
epstein
dock on netflix right oh dude i couldn't
watch it amy jamie and i were watching
it together i shut it off after the
first 15 minutes
yeah i was like i don't want to hear
about this i know what happened here's
the thing
obviously fluff piece like well we can
get into that but like
to like put all the guilt on epstein
type of thing like he's the sole purpose
like he manipulated everybody it was
like really adorable how they did it
kind of like you know fire fest they
made it look like that guy billy was
just the only guy that did anything
wrong
like all these things oh god yeah it's
like the second someone can't refute the
evidence like billy was in jail they're
like okay we're on the docks right and
it's like
and and you know how like so like there
were these pr companies that were
attached to firefights
right they promoted this [ __ ] everywhere
and all of a sudden they're like
absolved of any guilt because it's just
this guy billy who did everything and
whatever doesn't matter same thing with
with epstein but what's interesting
about the girls and
was like you just got to hear their
stories like i never heard of any of
these girls right
and after watching the stories and how
like they complained to the fbi the
complaints all these different places
and like nobody ever listened to them
i go oh [ __ ] this is why the me too
movement existed
because as a dude that came into the
metoo movement not
never being a douchebag to girls like i
never [ __ ] mistreated women at all
i was very good to girls like i looked
at me too and i was like what's going on
here like why are these girls
like so angry at us i'm i'm the worst
version of guy in terms of maybe like
dating a lot
i would never do anything yeah you're
not a boss
no no no but here i'm saying this is
what's really interesting the girls
tried to be heard for years they weren't
all of a sudden the voices are heard
right
i'm sure those aren't the only girls who
talk to their boss or talk to hr about
like their boss being inappropriate and
we're told to shut the [ __ ] up
so the second they're listened to
the floodgates are open right you see
what i'm saying
and i was like oh that's why this
happened this is like the straw that
broke the camel's back
type of thing exactly and and if i look
at it through that perspective even in
the time i go yes this is wrong and
saying things like
you know absolutes like believe all
women that kind of stuff is is wrong
and probably wouldn't even be supported
by them but i get the feeling
where it's like if nobody's gonna listen
to you and now you got a microphone yeah
you're going to scream into that [ __ ]
i don't even think it's the rational
ones that are saying it that are saying
believe all women i think it's a lot of
a lot of that [ __ ] is crazy people like
yeah just that
slogan is not something you could say
you can't say believe all men you can't
say
you can't say that because then you're
giving people the license to [ __ ]
you
yeah because you're not treating there's
like if someone tells you a story
and in this story whether you know
whoever it is you it's your boss
you're the victim of your boss if you
don't know the boss's version of it you
don't really know the truth
it's hard it's hard to say yeah it might
very well be they're telling you the 100
truth
or they might be a [ __ ] crazy person
who blames
everybody for everything that ever
happened in their life and they might be
a pathological liar there's a lot of
people that are just liars there's a lot
of people that are manipulators
they make up stories of course to make
other people look bad of course
but the nature of man is that men are
disgusting and when men are in control
like if a guy is the head of a [ __ ]
movie studio
yeah he can get these all these dime
pieces to suck on his sl
yeah yeah they've been doing that since
the beginning of time
yeah and the problem is not just that
the man
wants to do that to all the actresses
yeah yeah there's another problem
that some of the actresses actively
manipulate that man
and seduce him so that they can get
ahead oh yeah
that's real too yeah 100 percent yeah
what's
real is that there were willing
participants
that that were they were if you're
benefiting from the system
why would you reject it now i'm not
making a statement about marco robbie
right i don't know what she's done in
her life and she probably earned every
single one of her roles
perfectly no question i don't even have
to name any names my point is you've
never heard her complain about hollywood
because she's getting all the roles the
girls in hollywood i hear complaining
are 50.
you don't think that's coincidental like
rose mcgowan
ages out of sucking dick to do the role
you son of a [ __ ] i'm just
saying dare you i just say it's isn't it
coincidental when you age out of some
[ __ ] you complain
we're like we're all guilty of it too
you see like all these comments i see
tons of comments be like
there's no jobs for like straight white
comics and it's like
you're 50. you know there weren't any
for 50 year olds yeah like that's a guy
who's
you know you're a dad now i think a lot
of times you see these
these things at convenience man it's
like i wouldn't want to comment on that
because i don't know what exactly what
her situation is
or any of theirs right but what i do
know i don't know either but you look at
the correlation you see like okay maybe
there was a time
where this type of behavior was was like
how you kind of work the system to get
ahead talk to whitney about it
yeah yeah i mean she's not gonna name
any names she'll [ __ ] tell you
that's exactly what some of them did bro
that's the thing that i've realized like
now is like
especially with politics which is so
smart is like
have you seen everything everything's
like this like a proxy war
like if if you have a message you have
to get across
right and you're a republican right if
you're a message you want to get if
you're a republican
you know that the left is going to
attack your identity first no matter
what the message is
so they find people who have identities
they can't attack and they prop
them up right like the gay asian dude
what's this guy he got beat up like they
got milkshakes on him or something like
that
oh andy no yeah and then candace owens
right like if
you're conservative and you want these
conservative points said you have to get
them
said by people that the right can't
criticize the left sorry the left can't
criticize for so it's like
if you or i say something we're like
looting is bad or something like that
right
uh easily what you wouldn't know you
wouldn't know what systemic oppression
is joe you're a [ __ ] white guy you
have all this privilege shut the [ __ ] up
but if you have someone whose identity
cannot be criticized you have to take
what they say at face value
so that's their proxies right like milo
is the first one of these guys yeah but
the
these two people that you're put using
an example are both
examples of people that have been
attacked by the left
but they're not attacked for their
identity and not immediately discredited
for that identity
they have to be discredited for the
words whereas you would be immediate
identity wiping away but what's what's
genius is the left does it as well
and this [ __ ] hit me because i'd be
looking at greta thunberg and i'm like
why the
[ __ ] are we listening to a [ __ ] kid
about anything right right
it drove me crazy and then i go and i'd
see the
the gun kids from florida from the
school that got shot up and i'd be like
why are we
listening to kids about guns and
legislation i'm like
holy [ __ ] they're making kids make all
the points
because you can't tell kids to shut the
[ __ ] up or you're an [ __ ]
if you're the adult telling a little
girl to shut the [ __ ] up you don't know
anything about the polar ice caps
you're an [ __ ] so if you just get
kids to make all your points for you
the right just got to go well it's good
the kids are involved in the political
process
well my favorite thing about greta is
they started off with climate change
she was talking about her future yeah
how dare you then she became a half tart
this co right didn't she go half tart
she did she went hannah gatsby right
it's like
she has autism is that what you're
saying someone told me she's half
[ __ ] i believe she has autism
that's the correct term what's the
difference um was she vaccinated do we
vaccines
did you have too much vaccines no
there's no issues with the vaccines
right it actually is a plus you know
doing the vaccines no no the the autism
it actually helps you focus on certain
things
like what i don't know i mean that's
what they say about people on the
spectrum yeah
let's ask ben shapiro you think he's on
it oh autistic adam smith that's what i
call him
dude let's go the free market isn't like
ask him about anything
you like doughnuts well i'm the best
donuts would be in the free market
bro turn it off for a second dude just
[ __ ] turn it and we get it you like
capitalism dude
turn it the [ __ ] down what i was gonna
say about that greta check is they
brought her on the covid council
i saw that i couldn't believe it she's
16. like why are you bringing her on an
infectious disease council for a
pandemic
that no one's ever faced before you know
who they wouldn't have on the council
rand paul who is an actual medical
doctor who actually
survived covet they didn't ask him to be
honest
why because he has controversial
opinions and maybe he thinks that it
wasn't the best idea to shut the [ __ ]
economy down for three months and have
everybody go crazy
bro it is what it is it is what it is it
is what it is you can't it's just
yeah we live in a weird [ __ ] time you
can't tell me that they didn't
calling her for a new issue and putting
her out there publicly is
so irresponsible because calling her for
any issue is irresponsible she's a
teenager
what do teenagers know well i think
please tell me what teenagers know they
know how to go to school
okay and uh they have less things in
their mind so they get better at
stuff quicker like if you want to be a
gymnast or a martial artist
when you're a teen you get way better
way quicker okay greta
if there's a tick tock dance that i need
to learn i guarantee
your autistic concentration is going to
make it perfect and you're going to get
down those steps you're going to be able
to do it
i don't need to know about [ __ ]
science from you i don't even need to
know about science from most
journalists i just need scientists to
tell me and then
i'm gonna i'm gonna actually ask
questions because that's what [ __ ]
science is
when did science stop being about asking
questions like if you ask any real
scientist they'd be like
yeah well the whole point is we just
poke holes in our theories and we just
do that constantly and that's actually
good science
now the second you ask a question you're
a heretic man
yeah if it's about gender yeah or if
it's uh about the economy or if it's
about climate change
yeah those things you're not allowed to
use science okay climate's changing
yeah but you can't you can't use science
to just
if you have like any scientific facts
that you try to bring
do you buy the what do you think about
you think climate's changing it's 100
changing it's changing for the better
um if you're in antarctica it's better
if you're in antarctica it's going to
get hotter and it's going to be
it's going to be there's going to be
give me the negation give me the
negative i i
literally when they describe it to me
extinction events for sure there's gonna
be a large number of animals that can't
survive in areas there'll be less water
in in in areas where it's hotter okay
animals are gonna die
maybe people are gonna die we can move
the people less crops yeah
it's not that easy but you're right yeah
we got food but for sure you can make
food anywhere i can make food in my
my backyard i can make food in my living
room the point about it is
if you in any way dispute the models
of what they're saying and have an
alternative perspective yeah that
alternative perspective
is never engaged that alternative
perspective is demonized
that perspective is you're you're a
climate change denier
and you're a bad person and and some of
them just have uh
data that they're going on like they're
talking about the raised carbon levels
in the atmosphere is actually better for
plant life
and that the more cause plants actually
take in carbon dioxide they breathe out
oxygen right and
there was some people that were talking
about how there is
there's some benefits to some forms of
life by an increased carbon count in the
atmosphere
it's a [ __ ] weird argument because
it's one of the factors that's
leading to the fact that the world's
heating up i mean
you're saying that it's good that the
world's heating up it's like well i
don't know
maybe we act like it's good we want to
be warmer you know i grew up in new york
obviously he likes to be warmer and i'm
sure that's just a surface level
argument that being said
i don't know if the conversation should
be
stop global warming at any cost
maybe it is better conversation to have
is like hey we should do it we can stop
global warming
but we can't kill the economy because
then we kill people anyway
that is true we act like we're in a
weird space where we just think you
could print money and everything's okay
this concerns me a little mm-hmm that
doesn't worry you it worries me
this that's why the pandemic thing
worried me the shutdown because it was
like
it's not that easy to restart everything
and there's a lot of things that won't
be there when you restart it including
they think something like 40 of small
businesses might go under
within the first six months that's
that's scary [ __ ] that's a lot that's a
lot so what is everybody gonna work for
target
walmart and large corporations all the
mom and pop stores go under all the mom
and pop restaurants go under
very dangerous time in that way because
then where are the jobs
you can't just go right back that is a
and that's going to lead to a lot of
suicide a lot of murder
a lot of crazy [ __ ] because people are
going to be desperate that's one of the
things they said about
northern california they had more
suicides from
co during the the crackdown than they
had from covet
more people died from killing themselves
there's a big uptick
big uptick in suicides one of swartzen's
buddies the sheriff
was telling him that they used to have
one a week and now they were having five
a day
somewhere somewhere in l.a like what the
[ __ ] man
so that's something that people need to
take into consideration you need to take
into consideration how many people are
going to become drug addicts
how many people are going to be severely
depressed and it might forever alter the
course of their trajectory in life yeah
they might have been on an upward trend
all sudden boom their business gets
taken away from them
and then they get desperate and then
they get sad then they and then they get
on antidepressants and then they zombie
out and then they never go anywhere
well they were on their way to having a
fulfilled life how many people broke up
with their [ __ ] loved ones
because they had to be with them all day
24 hours a day and they were just sick
of them
maybe they would have worked out great
if they just went along at a
natural trajectory yeah how about if you
just start with a girl you just meet her
even date for a couple weeks and like
all of a sudden the pandemic hits and
you really like her
yeah like i just let's just live
together [ __ ] it
and you're like how long is it gonna
take you tell your friends like you sure
it's a good idea andrew
you've only known her for 14 days we
bought a dog
bro we bought a [ __ ] golden doodle
bro
it's true you ever call your buddy uh
from a new number
and this girl answers the phone girl
answers the cell phone hello
yeah um i'm calling for greg yeah
who's this yeah greg's friend who the
[ __ ] are you
that's the real question is greg you
have a secretary what is this
i was like oh yeah man that's my
girlfriend she didn't recognize the
number who got locked up she didn't
recognize the number
oh so she just answers your phone and
she doesn't recognize the number
yeah what what are you talking about man
yeah
yeah could you imagine yeah it's uh i
don't know
i've had i've been very lucky like i you
know me and my girl live together and
well you would tolerate you had a great
say again you would tolerate nothing
less you got a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah that's the other thing it's like i
cannot function well
in uh misery yeah i won't tolerate
misery dude i would hate to be a woman
working for a guy who wanted to [ __ ] me
it would probably be
horrible dude being a guy wanting to
work for
like oh my god for there was a guy who
was your boss who wanted to [ __ ] you
oh i was thinking like a girl boss but
also that that sucks girl boss would be
rough too
but yeah if a guy was putting a pressure
on like
if a guy was really like rubbing your
shoulders like guys do the tricks at
work like
like laying the meat on your back a bit
oh i knew a casting agent that was a
female that was kind of gross and she
would [ __ ] dudes
and get them rolls yeah oh yeah she'd
throw it around
back in the got a lot of fellas on a lot
of projects
really did you get something no yeah
but she tried to [ __ ] one of my friends
that was the only thing
hey hey there was a girl i guess i
shouldn't doubt her but
i got i'm not out in anybody i won't say
names but i think there was a girl that
worked at a comedy club in new york
that would uh [ __ ] a lot of comments and
get them on the stage i think that's how
it works and that's basically
way back in the day it's way back but
did misty yeah but listen here's the
deal
here's the difference yeah i support
that keep going
no one's getting killed see what i'm
scared about with women is that men are
physically stronger
yes when the man is physically stronger
the woman can just basically just [ __ ]
him
yeah they only have sex with them yes
the sucky thing is if it affects your
career
i get that but there's a big difference
between that and worried you're actually
going to get raped or worried you're
going to get killed
what women have to worry about with guys
that want to [ __ ] them is creepy angry
guy
type [ __ ] yes with men have to worry
about just lies
they have to worry about like hysterical
lies and crazy people making things up
or maybe the new boyfriend
coming over to kick your ass that's the
kind of stuff you have to worry about
you have to worry about
you know less things and you don't have
to worry about any of it during sex
that's what i was saying if you're gonna
was it andrea lima
who's the girl adriana yeah adriana lima
joint basketball court nothing around no
physical objects
yeah she can't kill you with anything
yeah if she she puts her pants on
screaming and runs out to the car
you got plenty of warning you grab a
chair yeah you know what you know what
you're doing what do you do keep it away
like a lion
oh okay yeah yeah yeah chair hey yeah
yeah
stop or stop one more time yeah yeah
one more is this but you're doing it but
my say my point is like it has to be an
extremely psychotic woman
for you to be actually worried about
your life yeah so if a girl comes over
your house
you might worry about your wallet if you
[ __ ] up and
you just barely know her and also she's
rummaging through your house
but you don't worry about your life yeah
you don't worry about yourself a woman
takes a guy over
her house she worries about her life
yeah she's terrified it's a different
thing
it's always gross when someone's using
their their power
to [ __ ] you mm-hmm whether it's a man or
a woman it's gross
but it's less gross when it's a woman
yeah
but power you mean physical power no no
what physical power for sure yeah i
meant like power
yeah like if they're your boss that's a
hard free slope though dude
don't you think it's like you can't use
power like that that's the weirdest
thing like
less gross though less girls but like
that wasn't
too much yeah well i don't know that was
the biggest issue with like with the
louis thing is like
louie i think said in his apology he was
like these girls admired me
and i used that or something like that
and i was like
who [ __ ] someone they don't admire like
that's
like their bare minimum yes of the
person that you're [ __ ] is admiration
right we just can't we can't start
labeling things
as sexual misconduct they're actually
good qualities to have in a man
but he has power that would have been
negated
but that would have been negated if he
actually had sex with them then there
was no issue at all
right the issue was he asked if he could
beat off in front of him and a lot of
women find that disgusting
yeah that's the issue if if he said do
you guys want to have sex and they said
yes
and then they did it there's no argument
yeah but if he said
do you mind if i beat off in front of
you and they said yes
people still judge bro that's the tricky
thing about apologizing bro
dude it's so you know what's crazy about
the public apology
is that like when you apologize publicly
you apologize
for whatever someone thinks you did yes
not for what you did you know what i'm
saying right so like if some
if some girl thinks that he slammed the
[ __ ] door held it down put an axe
there and
started [ __ ] whacking and want to see
the fear in their eyes
that's if that's what they think and
then he apologizes for and he as he says
my actions or whatever
everybody who believes that's what
happened is confirmed that's why i don't
know if you could ever publicly
apologize because you just confirm
everyone's suspicions when you do it you
have to clearly state
exactly what happened for the apology if
you
apologize publicly yeah he doesn't want
to do that
because it's embarrassing well his
version of it's very different than the
version that gets
spouted around yeah and whenever that's
the case
there's no way to know now it's a back
and forth there's no yeah there's no way
to know who's telling the truth and
who's not but
yeah the very least he had a funny bit
about it
he's saying even if they say yes don't
do it
yeah if you're ever thinking of jerking
off in front of somebody even if they
say yeah
it's like even if they say yes i heard a
good hypothetical
tell me what you think about this god
forget where i heard it i want to give
credit but uh
okay you know how like if somebody if an
artist does an unthinkable action
we cancel their art like maybe watching
cosby's specials are [ __ ] up or maybe
you take them off the air
off the air because right yeah if a
scientist
did some foul [ __ ] back in the day like
every greek scientist would just
bang in 14 year old girls no dudes
actually dudes right yeah yeah
but it was okay back then okay keep
going
this is interesting yeah it was okay
back then
times change now it's not okay yeah
right do we stop
using [ __ ] algebra no we don't
and i know there is a distinction and i
understand where like the art is like a
piece of you
and math is something that you find
right math always exists
right that being said i bet you there
are some people who would cancel
the scientists yes and what if art this
is and i'm not one of these [ __ ] like
hippie art guys but like what if art had
like
healing quality you know like some
people like songs can lift their mood
and like movies and stuff like that like
can like ease pain and like ease trauma
that they went through you know for sure
and it's like like my girl has all these
amazing childhood memories about harry
potter
you know so like any time we're in a
fight i just put in a harry potter and
then
we're [ __ ] everything's good it's
like love's done it's amazing dude it's
it's it's amazing we just source her
stone boom i'm backing it everything's
fine
but so what if you could make that
argument would you be like hey this is
very powerful this is very important
work
you can't cancel is that is that the
michael jackson effect like did michael
jackson make such good music yeah
that's the art it's more than art yeah
that's the argument with woody allen as
well
roman polanski same argument that like
you go back and watch rosemary's baby
even though you know he's a piece of
[ __ ] right because the art is so good
and so valuable
valuable it approaches science and its
value yeah there's something about it
where it's also ingrained into people's
lives i guess
bill cosby was so egregious and what he
did was on a network television it
wasn't like he was making films
you know what's wild is that like cosby
was like
you know putting [ __ ] in there you know
drugging people and [ __ ] them right
mm-hmm
joe exotic
was drugging dudes and [ __ ] them yeah
but they wanted to be drugged
they were hanging around good point good
point good point good point good point
they're already meth down they married
him
come on yeah dude meth is a powerful
drug it's a powerful drug dude that is
that dude's teeth it shows you
everything you need to know about meth
do
you do with the four teeth that's what
was that line somebody that's a hell of
a drug what was it
but cocaine don't make you gay bro maybe
math does
meth is that good maybe they're just gay
i don't know dude maybe they just can be
tricked into being gay
it's like we were talking about earlier
i really do believe that people can be
talked into things
all kinds of things sure for sure really
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i had a bit about it okay i had a
bit i had a bit about
mormons okay because mormons there was a
thing called uh proposition eight and it
was all about gay marriage it was
repealing gay marriage and
you know what was crazy was um that
mormon the mormon church spent a lot of
money trying to repeal gay marriage and
i said if anybody
should be scared of gay marriage it
should be mormons okay
because someone can talk you into being
a mormon
they can definitely talk in a soccer in
their dick they just need more alone
time with you
like you really you really believe a 14
year old boy
found golden tablets that contained the
lost work of jesus but only he could
read it because he had a magic rock
like someone if some guy can get you to
suck his dick he's just got to be around
you long enough and tell you that the
prophets
told him to tell you that there's wisdom
in his dick too that you have to do
something that seems horrible
to get the glory of god 100 percent you
remember that documentary
that came out about the guy who like
[ __ ] the whole family
remember he [ __ ] the mom the dad and
the kid
yes they were mormon oh no of course
interesting but i still i don't know i
don't know
they get super gullible when they're in
that fundamental religion that doesn't
make sense
right people that buy into religions and
grow up in religions that don't make
sense yeah i know a lady who was a
mormon and she actually admitted this
yeah it was her admission that made me
think about it yeah she goes i have
so much vulnerability when it comes to
people who are like crazy yoga guys
or cult members like i buy into it
because
she grew up her whole life in this
fundamentalist religion where you just
believe
nonsense so you're used to handing over
your consciousness to nonsense
let me see if i can poke holes in it let
me see
let me see here i yeah you become
trained to believe yeah and not be
skeptical
yeah so that anything that makes you
feel good and included
you feel like oh it's true it's rewarded
yes yes yes
hokey [ __ ] homeopathic [ __ ]
yeah all kinds of nonsense that people
believe reiki healing
yeah i'm gonna touch you and heal you
with my my hands
yeah all that nonsense you know and we
were talking about earlier about
people in their art yeah and people
being cancelled and their art gets
canceled
whether or not they do do that with
scientists there's actually a great
example of that
there's a guy named fitz harbor fritz
harbour and
fritz haber that's how you say it and
fritz haber uh
invented the harbor method of extracting
nitrogen from the air
that's responsible for a giant
percentage of the fertilizing
like when you eat food like i think they
say that fifty percent of the nitrogen
in most people's bodies
actually comes from the haber method he
figured this out in like
i guess it was world war one or world
war two
and then one world war one so he figured
this out
and then right afterwards he figured out
how to make zyklon gas
okay so he made zyklon a gas which was a
gas that was a pesticide
and they used zyklon a gas for
um for crops to kill off bugs and it
stunk
to high health was [ __ ] horrible so
um it had this smell attached to it the
nazis
turned that into zyklon b and were
gassing
jews with his invention on top of that
during world war one he talked the
germans into using
poison gas on the troops so on the
allied troops there was the first war
where they used like large-scale gas
weapons yeah
and so he was both at both at the same
time
getting the nobel prize for for the
harbor method of
extracting nitrogen from the atmosphere
and then on top of that
wanted for crimes against humanity
[ __ ] so he was wanted for war crimes for
gassing
yeah the first time they've ever used
poison gas on troops it was thought to
be a
terrible violation of the rules of
engagement have we
developed a new uh fertilizer thing no
we still use that
that's still the the standard there's
two ways of getting nitrogen you either
get nitrogen through natural sources
which is like fish and fertilizer and
cow manure and all those types of things
and
that's what compost is for and you get
it that way yeah
or you get it from the hauber method
because the the oxygen like when you
think about air
that's the best argument for like what
is it mulching what is the thing not
mulching
compost that's the best argument for
compost it's like don't support the
nazis
right but he's already dead yeah it's
large scale like large scale composting
is a real issue
you need a lot of biological waste to
make some large scale composting yeah
but the this hopper thing is really it's
a crazy story man
yeah because it sort of embodies like
this this situation where you got
a guy who did this incredible thing that
helped so many people but also did this
horrible thing that killed so many
people yeah
why were the germans so advanced
technologically at that time i don't
know man they
advanced with engines with car design
rocketry but why what is it it's hard to
say
i mean they're just brilliant [ __ ]
people it's not like they weren't in
close proximity to other people in
europe
you would feel like you think that like
that technology would would be shared
that's just so did it so it was so crazy
how advanced they were that the united
states took the nazis in to run nasa
right yeah yeah space force force
yeah it's new um operation paper clip
they brought in right yeah yeah the
russians too i think they like split up
all the scientists
yeah i went either to russia or the
united states all those the biggest
killers and wernher von braun was a
[ __ ] straight-up nazi
really yes the simon wiesenthal center
said that if he was alive today that
would prosecute him
for crimes against humanity werner
von braun the guy who's the head of nasa
[ __ ] bro
awful [ __ ] man yeah yeah they used to
hang the five slowest jews in front of
his rocket factory in berlin
yeah yeah dude like real legit nazi [ __ ]
yeah whoa yeah that was the head of nasa
they just took all those brilliant
scientists look at him there he is
werner von braun with all the nazis
yeah big smile oh it is interesting that
like
they nev like the brands that happened
around the nazis never like rebranded
like you know how like like volkswagen
is still
volkswagen people's car yes like which
people
right you know which people right and
then like hugo boss
i think is just hugo boss like if you
have a
little boss was a they made the [ __ ]
outfits
oh that's right didn't we talk about
this but isn't that like
don't you know how now if you have like
a little like pizza hut was like we
remade the pizzas they're way better
like
you would think that you would rebrand
if you're attached to that you'd switch
the name up
right you know in some way jake boss
well they used to people had a different
sensibility when it came to things back
then what do you mean because you got to
think
because they let things go like the only
thing that never let go
is the swastika you can't bring back the
swastika yeah but like
in those days it's an indian thing right
isn't it a hindu
yeah it is symbol yeah so these poor
indians are walking around
say again it's in the other direction oh
okay but um but still you can't wear it
hogan's heroes was a [ __ ] sitcom
about
nazi concentration camps yeah i mean
they joke around about it in the 1970s
and that was just 20 years afterwards
dude that's an interesting
like discussion it's like imagine we had
a sitcom about 9 11.
yeah dude that's what hogan's heroes is
like yeah same amount of time
yeah that's crazy yeah dude there was a
time
i'm trying to think i'm trying to see if
it's possible but like where like comedy
and
corporations could work together what
was this
at the time you're describing like i
don't think comedy and corporations can
work together i think it's very
difficult
right so it's like well because they
think comedy have to work with
corporations so they couldn't work at
all
right but the corporations were like
okay just be funny that's fine you could
do a show about this
like oh you mean a show about like
they're not like nazi concentration
camps
exactly like they're not police i mean
insane
and you know the dude bob crane on the
far right was a
freak well he was like one of the first
guys to film himself [ __ ]
okay it was like a great great uh great
kinder movie
big cameras back then big big you need
like another person
film yeah it wasn't like your iphone
which is nice and silent yeah yeah
you had to like set it up at the back of
it
have a dude cranking it out while you're
banging bro who is filming
somebody had to do it he um there was a
movie called
uh was it called something focus
autofocus right i think it was called
autofocus but it was a film
about him and he got murdered by this
dude that he used to
bang girls with why because they had a
dispute they had a falling out maybe
they touched dicks
and that you know what happened
something happened but it's a crazy
movie yeah it shows you how this guy
was just like he was a sad sitcom but
he's like
[ __ ] movies man i just want to bang he
just was
he just became a porn star i think about
that all the time
think about that all the time just
[ __ ] what was on
i don't know i think back then there was
just very few rules
is this the movie autofocus or we just
cared less about [ __ ]
yeah there was life wasn't that good
well i think there was just less people
yelling at you they made the wrong
choices too
what about there was no social media
back then that's also true right yeah so
the
less people have a voice about what's
wrong but i also think like
in times of luxury rules present
themselves
and then in times of chaos rules strip
like at least in new york i don't know
how it was here but like during during
the shelter in place during the pandemic
there was no more rules
right like same is here hey you can't
drink alcohol in the streets and then
all of a sudden it was like
yeah i guess you can right like like
they just said you can
and then there wasn't it was dangerous
there was anything like that you can't
deliver alcohol you can only deliver
food oh yeah you can deliver alcohol you
can't serve out you can't
eat on the street without a permit okay
you could eat on the stream without it's
just exposed
that's all this corona thing did it
expose a lot of [ __ ] it definitely
did
like it [ __ ] it took the makeup off
you know what i mean like you know like
you're at the club and like the girl is
like beautiful and then like you guys go
for like a skinny dip and then you're
just like whoa dude
you [ __ ] tricked me dude
and i feel like yeah like that happened
that happened with [ __ ] tv
well they adapted right they adapted
with these new looser regulations in
order
to keep us safe during this corona time
how does it keep me safe
i saw the funniest thing today was that
something that said use social
distancing
unless you're protesting can i tell you
something bro you see that
they put it on fox it was like an
official report i got the screenshot
in here i'll beat you to it jamie i
couldn't believe this
let me find it there it is right here
look as public health advocates
as public health advocates we do not
condemn these gatherings as risky for
kova 19 transmission
what this should not be confused with a
permissive stance on all gatherings
particularly protest against stay home
order so
protest again stay at home that you can
get corona
that hey don't say corona five times or
corona comes right
but protest for anything else i think
you're good it is really interesting
isn't it
it's pathetic what is it it's tell me if
this is unexpected
but what if tell me this is right what
if
we s in support of black lives matter
donated a percentage of all of our live
shows so that we could have full
audiences
now it's a public gathering in support
of this cause and we're putting money
towards the club
putting money in our mouth now some
people of course say you're using this
cause to perform in front of more people
then you're right yeah but at the same
time we're doing the right thing
everyone's benefiting it's mutually
short
that would be interesting i'm just
it's but then but then you're giving up
your power
to whether it's black lives matter or
whatever you give it up
your ability to just have a show
it's based into it really should be that
you want to give money to
valid organizations right of course of
course
but the idea that you could get away
with it like if we
we have like a three-month exemption
window where you could uh you could have
full crowds
until they lift it you can only have
full crowds if you give
five percent to fill in whatever the
blank whether it's black lives matter
whatever
whatever people decide isn't this how
they treat rich people anyway
hey rich people you gotta pay taxes yeah
unless of course you'd like to donate to
a charity
and then you have to pay that in taxes
exactly you could take some of that out
yeah that's true in that way you can
kind of decide
where your taxes go and then who wins
these organizations that are
truly trying to help people but then
will the organizations drop it after a
while like when do you have to keep
paying them
oh it's like what happens with them they
become a big corporation
and then they shame people for not
paying right and then it becomes a thing
like if you don't
pay you don't care they have power over
you and this is one of the things that
happened with kovid
yeah the people that were screaming wear
a [ __ ] mask we're a [ __ ] mask
oh they have power over you to tell you
to wear a mask are they really concerned
is that what's really going on
because it turns out historically they
were wrong they were wrong you're wrong
and yet you still
you can't go to places i go to tacos in
santa barbara yesterday i don't want a
[ __ ] mask
can i tell you they're good tacos
where'd you go because i was in santa
barbara
so we've had this conversation taco do
you remember the place i don't some
outside joint
it's the [ __ ] oh it's an outside joint i
was probably right there with you
i don't remember the name it's called
shall hoobs could have been
they go um please put your mask on as we
take you to your seat
now when we're at your seat you can take
your mask off
hilarious can anybody explain to me what
they thought i was going to do
in the 10 feet before shame
that's la now la is opening up
restaurants and i had uh
my friend janet and evan uh the the
janet
is the uh owner and evan is the lead
chef of this
restaurant felix in uh venice okay and
they said that when people are in the
restaurant people have to
wear their mask until they sit down then
when they go up to pee if they get up to
pee
they have to wear their mask if you go
to leave you have to wear your mask
there's no size there's no sizes you're
all in a box together and this is a
intimate restaurant in venice it's not a
big restaurant
it's the weirdest it's [ __ ] dummies
that they [ __ ] up the first thing
now they're [ __ ] this up yeah because
they just don't want to admit they're
wrong
they just don't admit they're wrong i
get it i've been in that you know i've
been in that argument you're with a
friend or with your girl or some [ __ ]
like that new zealand life's locked down
as it declares virus eliminated
for now and what did they do well
there's only like a million people there
no active coronavirus cases and no new
infections wow
but you can't go over there right like
get out of here you dirty [ __ ]
yeah they have a they have a beautiful
country with very few people
i mean i think the whole population of
new zealand is like what is it like 10
million
they are letting some exceptions though
some people can come in
yes like oh for instance james cameron
and the people making avatar too
oh my goodness so there are exemptions
for professional purposes
i see how it works well if you had a
show booked what if andrew and i have
would have uh style bender
how about i take a test there's no way
to take a test without shoving that
[ __ ] thing all the way down
you see now the new one just a little
q-tip it just barely goes in the inside
of your nose
and then done and then you're done yeah
um i haven't taken a test
i've taken seven of them i think and
you're passing yeah every one of them
yeah
i don't know dude i don't i don't know i
don't think i yeah maybe i got it i
don't know maybe
you take vitamins no never no hmm
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know i just i think i got
like i don't know like
i knew i was over it say again how well
do you eat i don't i don't know i just
eat in the morning
then yeah i just i don't eat a lot of
bread and i don't need a lot of refined
sugar or none i try to cut them all out
that's good
yeah my girl's an amazing cook so she
throws it down oh there you go
and then yes i'm eating healthy i'm
healthy yeah i try to exercise but like
i did it you know i was like super
you know put the lotion on the hands and
cover everything up for like maybe a
couple weeks and then i was like nah
that's not gonna happen
i was nervous yeah i'm not gonna lie in
the beginning two weeks ago
when did you stop care i knew i knew the
moment i stopped karen well i got my
first test
i took my first test like uh maybe
three week two three weeks in yeah
everybody was clear i was like all right
we're all good
my whole family was good and then um i
started testing everybody
in here yeah and then i knew eight
people that got it
yeah and the eight people that got it
everyone was fine except for michael yo
michael yo got it pretty bad yeah but
in the interest of telling the whole
story if anybody ever have heard this
already i'm sorry
but michael yo flew all the way to new
york no sleep
does [ __ ] press does radiology did
two shows
did choose two shows the next day flies
back home no rest
gets in the car drives to vegas to see
his wife's family
hangs out there for a little bit drives
home same night
next day auditions next day after that
more auditions so you got no sleep
worn out a lot of travel stress stress
stress and then audition stress
and then boom it hits him it hit him and
it hit him pretty bad and then
he uh got on advil and he said that
once he took started taking advil it
[ __ ] spiked and he got real bad
wanna being hospitalized meanwhile his
mother
got it and she was she's in her 70s i
believe yeah
kicked it in a day yeah one day because
she wasn't traveling she wasn't wearing
herself out she eats healthy whatever
whatever the reason is i'm i firmly and
he also had deficient vitamin d
he that was a problem with uh with
michael yeah i think
mike just caught the perfect storm of
being tired he felt like he might have
been run down already like maybe he had
a little bit of a cold
yeah then got the covid yeah and got the
code with a bunch of his friends
and i think they were all fine they all
they all got it they got sick a little
bit but then they walked it off
yeah i think that's the case but he got
it real bad
yeah he's the only one that i know that
got it real bad yeah everybody i know
that got it they
they got sick they coughed a little bit
and then after a while it was over
yeah it's just tricky you just don't
want to kill your dad
you want to kill your mom like that's
really what it comes down to like i
don't give a [ __ ] for we
we said like the guys that that um that
work with me
uh we all basically said you know if one
of us gets it we all get it yeah and
that was the thing we just kept working
that was right
but i mean yeah you know just white boy
fun you know yeah
yeah yeah um the other thing is
like spitting each other's mouth while
you're riding a bull that's white boy
[ __ ]
yeah um one of the things they were
saying is with kids yeah they were like
my kids they were like you know we don't
know they're ever going to be able to go
back to school again
i might have to do remote schooling and
all this different my kids aren't even
getting sick
yeah and if they do get sick it's not
very many of them meanwhile you don't
shut down
[ __ ] yeah the flu and the flu kills kids
yeah this disease kills an incredibly
small number of children it's always a
tragedy when a kid dies
disease yeah so it's not like we're
saying that those kids don't count
right but to say that it's dangerous for
kids it's like
it's dangerous for a very small number
of kids yeah very very small the flu
is dangerous for all kids the flu
[ __ ] kills kids
right you don't test these teachers to
see if they have the flu you don't test
to secure you don't test people you tell
them if they have the flu stay home
yeah you get the flu all the [ __ ]
time yeah and last year in america 61
000 people died from it from the flu
so more people died from covid yeah i
don't know how many more
i don't know i don't know i mean i think
that the number they're attributing it
to
to it is 110 now 110 000. but i don't
know if that's
more or less than the real number
because they're wondering
like how are they are people dying of
covid that they're not counting
are people dying of other things they're
counting it as covid yeah there's a lot
of
dispute as to what the real number is
let's say it's accurate yeah
110 it's basically less than twice as
bad as a bad flu i don't think that's
enough to shut down the [ __ ] economy
yeah i think people need to take
make good choices but meanwhile they
don't say a word about taking care of
yourself
not a word not a word about don't drink
so much not a word about don't eat sugar
not a word get your sleep yeah here's
how important sleep is
to your immune system not a word yeah
what do you think what do you think
changes what do you think doesn't
recover
after this like you think people
restaurants are [ __ ]
i think people go right back they will
go right back but the restaurants don't
have the money to stay open
oh yeah so like businesses that operate
on the fringe yes are done like the
businesses are like all right i got
money this month we can stay open
i think they they operated in a world
that never considered that we could have
some sort of calamity like this
well that was what janet the owner of
felix was saying is that most
these restaurants they operate on you
know they make like 14
profit yeah that's like what they
operate on if you shut them down for
three months they're
[ __ ] yeah and some of them don't even
operate well that well
they're operating on four percent profit
right you know they're barely making it
they're barely getting by they're not
doing so well
yeah it's like yeah corona exposed
pre-existing conditions
both physically and economically you're
right like if your business
had these pre-existing conditions you
were barely surviving
corona's cutting you out of there you're
right i think that's i keep on looking
at like tv
you know like you see all these like
shows going to being filmed in their
home
and it's like oh [ __ ] like jimmy fallon
like found
all these guys they're doing it in their
home now and it's like weird
not only is it weird like without all
the lights yeah without all the makeup
how about no audience without the laughs
the laugh tracks all of a sudden it
looks real elementary right yeah
and and people kept hitting us out like
you were so gracious you you know
repost all this stuff and like for me
when i saw everybody come to youtube
i was like oh it's a home game now
like like like the second night
like you can't go to the studio and we
had the studio built
and my guys were like timing in your
studio perfect timing bro it was
and if i if i had to explain to anybody
why i was going to build a studio prior
to all this they'd be like you are the
stupidest guy with money i've ever heard
in my entire life
really they were saying that no they
didn't say it but if i explained like
how much money i spent on the studio and
i had zero way of making the money back
because i never i know this is bad like
investment strategy but i never go
oh if i put this in now 10 years is
later all i go is i really want to do
this
and if i love this enough i'll find a
way to make money
on it right like i live my whole life
honestly
if you're investing in [ __ ] companies
that you have no clue what they are
maybe you do it other way but if you're
investing the [ __ ] that you love
it will work out it sounds stupid we
sound like gary vee but you know what
but you know what go sell some [ __ ] in
your backyard it works because you're
chasing what you really enjoy
you know that if you build this studio
you'll get to do some of the clips like
these things that you're putting up on
instagram
and it's what you really enjoy dude it
is
it was so cool it was so cool just to
see everybody come in
and it was like you know you know in the
super superhero movies where like
the super villain loses their powers
yeah and then has to fight
like fight the hero on like even playing
grounds and it's like oh
this is what we're doing now yes it's
over because i really
i really genuinely believe and it's a
pain that like it's hard work putting
out the pieces man and shout out to my
guys who do amazing job mark gagnon
comic he writes it with me and i love
him
alex matthews yeah and you know we stole
the uh
the john oliver graphics did you or like
background
where they go it's no not where they go
but like the uh the image like the
imagery in the background
we literally just looked at every show
we're like all right who's the best
and we're like we want to look just like
them so they compare us immediately
it was like i want the smoke right now
it's like now for once you guys
gotta [ __ ] compete with me right you
know you gotta do it grassroots
we're in the [ __ ] jungle it's just
youtube clips it's just
you guys making it so you're unshackled
i like the prolific use of the word
[ __ ] is a perfect example
yes unshackled you could basically say
whatever you want to be funny
yeah because who's cancelling me yeah
i'm strong you're hamstrung
first of all it has to be a television
show keep keep going this is interesting
yeah
it has to be a television show which has
advertising
so it has to be even though he's on the
internet now essentially
i mean he's doing it from his home from
a webcam you still have to do it on the
same fcc restrictions
you don't have to do that you buck wild
you put it on youtube and putting those
clips up on instagram not only fcc
uh constrictions dnc constrictions you
know what you got to say
yeah you know you got to tell the
company you know it's like
yes you have affiliations honestly i
really believe the reason why our [ __ ]
blew up
so quick outside of you reposting it
obviously that's magnificent thank you
so much but like
keep doing it 100 keep posting it we
will i really believe
and i think it's a similar effect to
what happened with you guys which was
we just said the truth
obviously in a funny way it's five
minutes jam pack a [ __ ] laser beam
somebody who needed some bars this week
someone who needed
to be told that they're [ __ ] idiots
right but we said
the truth doesn't have a party and if we
just find truth and i'm not talking
about statistics or any of that kind of
[ __ ] i'm literally talking about gut
feeling funny
[ __ ] once you look at biden yes you're
not going this is a president
right right you're not going you're not
saying that at all no
so it's like and i'm just sitting here
i'm going is nobody [ __ ] talking
about this
like i'll message some guys that work
for cnn i want to say their names but
i'll just dm my big bro i appreciate
your support you're great you're sweet
is he senile they'll say yes
and i'm like why aren't you staying on a
[ __ ] tv because they want him to win
no matter what
i know so everybody want trump this is
the thing with the um
what i was saying with like corporations
and comedy
what do we do as comics we make fun of
the absurd the [ __ ] ass the asinine
we make fun of institutions that's what
we do
you and i will be out there we'll be
[ __ ] playing pool
and we'll be thinking about these
institutions that we want to give
justice to in a weird way we give
justice with words right but like you're
not going to get away with it and that's
what we operate we operate in the space
like oh no you're not getting away with
it
right but right now there's such a cost
for saying the wrong things even in your
friend group even your friend group
so what we basically said is when we sit
down we're like okay i know i feel this
way about something
we're gonna construct an argument around
this thing that is true that is so
solid yeah i don't care if you're on the
left or the right you cannot refute it
right and it's [ __ ] painstaking yes
but it works and
the coolest thing is seeing these people
on the left and the right
watch this clip both find it funny and
both agree
and you realize 99 of us are not left or
right there's one [ __ ] issue that
takes us over
we're literally in the middle watching
these idiots on either side of the
extremes say stupid [ __ ] we don't give a
[ __ ] about
99 of us are right here and there's a
lot of us in the middle
okay 90 in the middle and then abortion
might take us left or right
but the rest of stuff yeah what the
economy
is is a few things but the thing about
the biden thing that made it so
maddening is it's not like he's the only
one
it's not like they didn't have a lot of
other candidates it's not like there was
a lot of other people they could have
put in office
that people would have voted for over
trump including bernie because guess
what right now don't get me started
bernie was running
right now if bernie was still in the
heat right now
he could have won you know you know the
uh the term a lot of people are saying
like
don't talk about the good cops because
if they were good they would have called
out the [ __ ] right
right yeah that's bernie to me in a lot
of ways right
bernie is and i [ __ ] support it
bernie man not because i agree with his
policies
at all i just thought he genuinely
wanted to help
he didn't want to win he seemed like he
wanted to help
and i was like i'll support a guy that
wants to help what was the bill that he
didn't show up to vote for i don't know
there was something jamie what was that
thing that had to do with
uh it was in the patriot act it was a
new revision that everybody was freaking
out
all the progressives were like bernie
didn't even show up for this
like that this is really important it
was uh it had something to do with
uh surveillance what does it have to do
with
put it up oh okay well check this out
man yeah if you want to be mad at him
more
well the senate voted to let the
government keep surveilling your online
life without a warrant yep
so for this yeah failed by just one vote
and it was burning that didn't show up
there's like three people here's the
thing here's the thing with bernie that
i'll say okay hold on a second
many senators wanted to forbid the
government from secretly collecting
information about your
internet habits but an amendment failed
by just one moment
meaning if bernie was there he could
have made that thing fail
could have stopped it but he didn't yep
he didn't
that is [ __ ] up look two others
ben sasse and bernie sanders didn't
respond to a request for comment
on where they were during the vote yep
couldn't vote because he's quarantined
what so one guy said he couldn't vote
lamar alexander couldn't vote because
he's quarantined
why didn't they just ask him hey lamar
can we get you on video
how you voting yay or nay yeah why do
you need to be in the room
right and then bernie didn't show up and
they didn't respond
to a request for comment on where they
were
during this important vote that that's
like
exactly what you were talking about this
is another great example the most
egregious example to me
is you got ass raped by the dnc
twice twice they bent you over no
saliva and [ __ ] you
and you didn't say [ __ ] just [ __ ] say
it dude
now granted you weren't good enough
trump is an example of someone who was
good enough to beat the party that
didn't want him to be there
right like nobody in the republican
party wanted trump to win right right
but then they all
eventually got behind it because you
told the company line whatever
he wasn't good enough and also the
democrats have systems that don't allow
that [ __ ] you know these super delegates
and all this [ __ ] right you get
sneaky
i love it when the democrats talk about
why do why do we need to abolish the
electoral college what about your
primary
yeah twice [ __ ] this old man but it's
like it's crazy
but but the thing is like you could have
done it man you had the opportunity well
how about the fact that they all
backed off at the same time and uh he
set his ass up
yeah yeah for super tuesday they said
his ass up they saw him said his ass but
call that out dude yeah call that [ __ ]
out yeah he's not that guy
i mean i don't know i mean he seems like
a really nice guy when i met him and
talked to him i think he's maybe too
nice
but the fact that he didn't vote against
that though yeah the ability to just
surveil you anytime they want without a
wire
without a warrant yeah it's weird i mean
i assume they're looking at all our [ __ ]
anyway
of course for you they're definitely
your [ __ ]
you think 100 why do you say that
because you're funny
you're funny you've got you've got a lot
of influence you talk a lot of [ __ ]
yeah i mean if somebody watches your
video on joe biden it's very possible
they might not vote for him
that's real interesting for sure listen
man this is a meme society
yeah you're barely paying attention if
you if you get into that box
yeah and and you and you start thinking
about some of the funny punch lines
you had in that joe biden video yeah
come on man people might go [ __ ] that
dude
yo andrew i said [ __ ] that dude i voted
for trump yeah
that's real possible man especially like
the midwest
the aries look california's not going to
matter in new york it's not going to
matter people vote blue
no matter who but when you get to those
middle states that can swing either way
who [ __ ] knows but you don't find it
weird dude that like
there's no fair
comedy in this lane and by fair i'm not
trying to say that people aren't unfair
like i think you know trevor and john
are really good you know like an snl
in these places but like i i know
what they're gonna say before they say
it right like i know the opinion before
they say it
right so doesn't that take away some of
the most
necessary component to comedy which is
surprise
well it's what dennis miller did back
when bush was president
right do you remember that no we do
wouldn't make fun of him he said i'ma
give him a pass he's my friend
nah bro nah bro you get these bars bro
everybody gets these bars that's that's
what you got to do you got to write the
ecosystem that's
i don't i hate over inflating our
importance as comics because i know a
lot of
people can do that but i really think
we're here to manage the ecosystem
well you know in other cultures it's
actually an important function
like in the lakota and the dakota
indians they had a thing called a heyoka
yeah and hiyoko was a guy who made fun
of everything it was a clown who was a
contra
contrarian yeah who mocked all the
important
things yeah and they they they were like
i mean that's my tour is called sacred
clown tour
for that that's why yeah that's like
that's what heyoka means
yeah to the lakota people it's a sacred
crown they understand the importance
a sacred clown someone who makes fun of
important things because it's important
anything that you can't make fun of is
[ __ ] yeah you can't make fun of it
yeah like like if you say
you know the lord's name in vain yeah
you can't say that don't say god damn it
like really like what what are you
saying like why can't i say it
what what what is it about not being
able to say things what is it
well people have power of you they can
tell you that you can't say those things
and whether it's talking about certain
subjects or using certain words
it's all the same thing it's people
enforcing their ability to call you out
and have control over you
but that and that's the thing where it's
like if you
where comedy and institutions are tricky
because
you can't make fun of the institution
you're in right
right so you have to make fun of the
opposite
institution even if you don't
necessarily believe that way right
so all these institutions tend to be
left-leaning
they only are allowed to make fun of the
opposite institution
exactly right so we hear we came in
literally just in the middle and going
oh yeah the joke is actually right wing
this
today or like yeah the topic is actually
left wing we balance side by side
but it's not it's not based on what the
institution wants us to be a part of
it's literally based on what the joke is
and what the best version of joke is
and what is what i guess i would call
like truthful
what is the truth like i want to make
the argument so you're not [ __ ]
scared to talk to your friends about how
you feel
bro if you tried to pull that [ __ ] off
on nbc they would pull you aside
doug they said they would have a their
conversation with you
this is it it drives me crazy man it's
like
honestly maybe it's in popular opinion i
don't know it's like
i'm i'm really impressed with with like
trevor and
john's uh john's got great writing bro
they
they they're great john is john is is is
really great the writing's really great
it's produced well
but i'm impressed that they even do it
like imagine like moving to another
country
and then immediately making fun of half
the country that you've never even
visited
you got some [ __ ] balls like if i
moved to england
and i lived in london and just trashed
northern england on a tv show
would that be i would never feel
comfortable doing that i'd be like i
don't know enough about y'all and like
that's weird for me to just do this for
a living guys that's not weird to you
it's weird like how accepting is america
we just let people just come and just tr
have you never lived in alabama is
alabama's a punch line have you ever
lived in alabama
arkansas is a punch line have you lived
there you know
it's just shocking to me that you could
feel comfortable doing that
and then i hear all these jokes about
like calling out the greed like
conservative greed
and it's like you guys could make tons
of money in your own countries
but you came here because you wanted
more
it you wanted more money
that's definitely true i'm just saying
dude it's just but it's also everybody
knows our politics
like our politics are global like you
you go to australia they make fun of our
president
you have no [ __ ] idea who the
president of australia is it's kind of
different in that way
and it's other thing the other thing
that's an issue is
we get hood winked by salesmen
with british accents every time keep
going
whatever it is watch late night tv when
someone's trying to sell you a [ __ ] up
mop that you don't really need
they're doing it through an english
accent they have a british accent they
have some sort of an accent
that makes them think they are superior
it is look at this product
it's an amazing thing look at what it
does it's a radio it's a blender
it's a fantastic accent whether it's
yeah whether it's david attenborough
yeah who's narrating something the guy
talks about beatles yeah like they're
the most fascinating thing
you don't want a guy from brooklyn
talking about
chimps you don't want a guy from philly
talking about tuna it's [ __ ] tuna
this is a robot
it [ __ ] its sister these tunas they're
out there in these gigantic packs
yeah they're swimming around even if
they're saying all the right words you
don't want them sounding like that even
if they're saying
super intelligent [ __ ] with any kind of
an east coast accent sounds dumb as [ __ ]
yeah same as southern right someone says
some like super intelligent [ __ ] about
the ocean the ecosystem but they say it
with a southern accent yeah what
yeah same words yeah british accent
we're all in
yeah so if someone is mocking our
culture
what better way than a culture that's
known
very proper so you think it's by design
they're like people will trust
these opinions more because it's coming
from these guys
who have this accent that has equity yes
interesting there's definitely something
to that you know because look they could
have hired al madrigal to run a daily
show they could have hired a lot of
other people that would have been
amazing at that job
i think john oliver is great i really do
i think he does a great job he isn't
funny about the way he attacks things
the show is
is is really well done yes the show the
writing too yeah it's the second best
show after ours it's really good it's
like a big show
but it's they're they're settled down by
the fact that they're on hbo
like if you're in that liberal
establishment
and you're in that like there's weird
conversations that are had
where people aren't looking at the jokes
that are about the left
they're not going to make fun of hillary
they're not they're going to not going
to make fun of joe biden yeah they're
not going to make fun of nancy pelosi or
any other prominent liberal that's not
going to do it even if the joke is there
so what's the point well it's weird
right it's [ __ ]
weird when you see it in the news right
like
the difference between the way they
covered uh women that had allegations
against trump versus women that have had
allegations
versus joe biden yeah very different
very different the way they cover it
yeah yeah it's true yeah there is that
there's that like obvious bias i guess
maybe it's like i was looking up like
news organizations i think like back in
the day
everybody knew that they were biased
like you just knew
yeah like like uh like late 1700s to
like early 1800s i think they even like
enacted a law that said you couldn't
criticize um the president or his views
or something like that in the press but
well that's how it is in china i mean
yeah journalists have [ __ ] been
ghosted in china
oh really oh my god yeah the people
disappear hundreds of journalists
they just disappear yeah dude they don't
[ __ ] around
in china yeah so then why can't they
close down the bat thing
well they i hate that they make this
argument that they have control of
everything and everybody can get killed
it's like well you can't just
close the market where they sell the
penguins first of all they did
kinda and then they opened back up in
like a week but but if you listen to
them
i don't listen to them i don't think
they're telling the truth but their
story is that only 30
000 people died now if you think about
the 110 000 people that died here and
then in china you're talking about
literally a billion people
come on bro yeah i don't buy it come on
bro i just
it's just it's a weird time man it's
like and i'm surprised these
corporations don't get it like when you
see platforms like this which literally
let people
speak and they have different opinions
and different points of view
and you see the entire world gravitate
towards it because we're addicted to
truth
yeah like we like truth we like to
confirm our bias
we like even more the truth you know i
mean like there's a reason why
conspiracies are so fun
right because we're like wait a minute
is that the truth like what's going on
in here i want to really know
like deep down don't you really want to
know what's going on you want to know
how all this [ __ ] works
oh yeah you know so it's like it's
exciting
yeah man it's also people like to solve
puzzles that's why that you
you go and you know you play games
people want to win yeah solve things if
i can catch you being a lizard person
behind the scenes look at that the
[ __ ] world's flat i knew it yeah look
at the evidence i'm going to send you
some evidence man i'm telling you i'm
going to change your mind
there's a lot of people that want to
tell you about things yeah you know i
got dude just sent me a bigfoot thing
the other day smart guy
believes in bigfoot yeah charlemagne
believes in bigfoot does he 100 yeah
well it used to be a real thing
that's the problem yeah it used to be
gigantopithecus they've actually found
bones of a large bipedal hominid that
lived as recently as a hundred thousand
years ago so it lived alongside of
people
and they found fossilized bones in china
in the 1920s
that this um there was an anthropologist
that visited this apothecary shop and
they found these
bones that were primate bones much
larger than any primate bone he'd ever
seen before
and so they said where'd you get this
and they took them to the site and they
started digging up bones
and so they know it was a real animal
that was uh they think it was
very orangutan like but it was huge
you never heard of it before never heard
of this show the uh the picture of uh
gigantopithecus
well here's where it gets even crazier
yeah this animal lived in asia asia
is connected by the bering strait oh so
you think they came together
in north america and that's why you see
it that's what it the northwest
see um go to which one that one right
there you just we just added a little
bit about right there bang
perfect look at that that's what it
would have looked like yeah
so that is a you know a recreation but
you're talking about a bipedal animal
that's eight to
ten feet tall and it was an enormous
primate
with like you know a bigfoot looking
face man just go to that picture just
make that picture bigger
that [ __ ] was bigfoot i mean
yeah so the reason why there's all these
stories
these myths is that at as recently as a
hundred thousand years ago
that was a real thing so people
definitely saw
that thing walking around yeah so they
probably
talked about it in folklore and in
stories and
who knows what the [ __ ] that thing even
ate i mean it might have ate people we
don't know
i don't know i mean there's a lot of
primates that eat other primates
like chimps eat the [ __ ] out of monkeys
really oh
david attenborough you want to watch
yeah okay pull up to david attenborough
they hunt they hunt monkeys
they corral them in it's the most
ruthless [ __ ] because there's a video of
this chimp
eating a monkey while it's alive it's
holding onto the monkey and biting its
hips
and just pulling chunks of meat while
the monkey's screaming like
like his little primate face screaming
while this monkey's just eating them
alive
i thought that they do like ants on a
stick or something they do everything
they can eat
they're omnivorous it means they mean
they eat everything
they're like humans yeah they're
omnivores yeah they eat meat
they eat vegetables they eat fruit but
they didn't
figure this out until the 1990s
attenborough was doing this documentary
and there it is so these trackers took
him
and they show how the monkeys
are um is this the one there's another
one
doesn't she see there is okay look at
that that is
a champ eating a monkey this one is uh
on the forest floor i think the one i
saw was uh in a tree this one shows a
chase
oh yeah yeah that was the monkey's hand
right there it is
this is the this is the video so um this
is really dark [ __ ] man because they
they
chase these monkeys and the monkeys get
scared they're trying to figure it out
and they're trying to run away but the
chimps are bigger and stronger
and they corral them in and so once they
get them
man they they're tearing them apart it's
horrible to watch
yeah yeah yeah see see now they're the
monkeys trying to get away
and uh this is the footage of the monkey
trying to escape and the chimp comes
chasing after him and grabs them and now
once he grabs them it's rough bro they
get they kill babies everything they eat
them all
so he grabs him she's got him there
you see that [ __ ] so he's gonna pull him
down
and then once the chimp has the monkey
he gets to a spot
where he can eat and i think they fight
over who gets to eat the monkey
and then eventually he wins but look
he's got this monkey in his hand
and he's going to just going to pull it
apart
it's rough man the when when you see
them eating it like look here it is
oh dude that's all it should i do i get
it i get it okay
you'd have oh god we'd have to get jamie
the right video in advance because
there's probably hundreds of them out
there but there's one that came from
that show that's really rough to watch
because this monkey uh is alive
and awake yeah this champ is biting them
and pulling them apart
yeah but anyway yeah you got it yeah
here it is
so here it is she's grabbing it look oh
dude
wasn't alive there but oh i did see this
is one where they're just pulling it
apart but there's
there's a great one where the the monkey
is [ __ ]
screaming oh i did yeah this is yeah
this is gnarly
it's hardcore man uh how do we get on to
this
um i don't know something
gigantic gigantopithecus might eat
people that's what it was thank you
jamie and why were we on gigantic
oh bigfoot's real because charlemagne
believes in bigfoot oh yeah
what is the real thing but here's the
thing did that thing eat people
i don't know if a chimp can eat a monkey
like that yeah why wouldn't that thing
eat a person where the monkeys
yeah probably everything that came out
that thing's so big if that thing
was omnivorous and i don't think they
know if it's
an herbivore effect i mean they didn't
even know chimps were like again until
the 90s
yeah this is just so all this [ __ ] is so
odd
like the deeper you go down the rabbit
hole the more you the less you
understand man
so where you see bigfoot like if you're
one of them bigfoot freaks
in the north it's all in the northwest
yeah the northwest it's all
i mean there's sightings all over the
country but that's just because people
are fully predominantly over there i
think
most of it was in that spot yeah
i mean that's a rainforest up there the
pacific northwest is so dense
i bet it probably lived there for a long
time yep you know and died off
that's all you need you need like a
shred of truth for stuff like
i remember when i was uh i was in egypt
right and i texted you when i was in
youtube because i watch every one of
your [ __ ]
i'm i'm going to cairo to like see the
pyramids right and i realized i haven't
even really researched the pyramids
so i do this deep dive and i'm watching
like graham hancock hancock and then
there's another guy
that you have carlson dr robert shock
maybe that was it yeah i don't know but
i like i'm just watching dr shock is the
geologist
that he was the one who passed recently
or something like that no no he's still
oh john anthony west
yes yeah yeah yeah okay he's the he's
the the god
father of it all yeah and um so i watch
i'm watching everything
i'm obsessed and uh we go and check them
out
and it was the single most like
unbelievable thing i've ever seen it
makes you like question reality a bit
really yeah like i get why people go oh
aliens in the same way like have you
ever seen the northern lights
no i haven't but like video you see them
in real life and you're like
oh [ __ ] what's going on like all right
god all right
yeah like it's believable and then when
you see them uh alaska
oh wow yeah yeah i did comedy just to
see them no i did comedy
yeah not in anchorage the other city um
juno
no it's like a little military fairbanks
fair banks really far north yeah yeah
cold up there yeah yeah yeah
what do you what time of the year was it
uh i don't know cold i
don't know i really don't know i forget
but maybe like maybe fall yeah fall or
something i guess it has to be
like the winter time right i don't think
it was winter i would have i would
remember if it was like cold cold okay i
think in fall
if it gets cold enough you can see him
so i'm one day the second i landed
right after the airport just fascinating
in the same way with the pyramids like
i remember watching them and i'm like
okay this question is reality like
things are different now and i remember
reading or watching the videos
and one guy said like time is it or like
human progression isn't linear
and that was the coolest argument i've
heard for it yes the idea that like
a society could pop up
be somewhat insulated so they had tons
of time and like wealth and i guess
wealth would be in resources back then
develop technology die out
that technology never goes to anybody
else it just exists and then dies and
then a few thousand years later
another group of people end up going
they're like oh there's some cool [ __ ]
i'll hang out
right and that is the most reasonable
explanation for me
is that they're really excited building
on that old stuff and trying to figure
out how they did it and do their version
of it
there's there's a bunch of different
very distinctive construction styles
like isn't that how we are as like
humans like
okay the empire state building is in
this neighborhood that's a cool building
yeah i want to build a building over
there how the [ __ ] do they do this i
want to hang out this is cool
and he broke it down he's dope [ __ ] he
was like that specific spot
is that there's an impenetrable forest
on one side and there's a desert on the
other side and there's a river that when
it overflows
just fruit and vegetables just starts
sprouting out of the ground it's like oh
this is how you would be able to have
the wealth in time
yes to develop cool [ __ ] exactly like of
course we're developing cool [ __ ] in
america because
we're not busy fighting [ __ ] in
our country right all the time like yeah
elon can develop all these cool things
drill a hole in the ground why who's got
nothing else to do
right we're not in war we're not [ __ ]
we're right like if you were at war
constantly how could you develop
right and they they were free for like
thousands of years thousands
of course you can develop cool [ __ ]
you'll find like i'm not talking about
like
internet but obviously cool water
technology i mean it completely is
plausible but
how they describe it no way and you know
it's not the same human beings because
cairo is a dump
like cairo is so awful that there's no
way that the people who made
cairo also made the pyramid perfect
there you are look at you handsome
bastards sculptured cheeks
i mean this is just it's unbelievable
dude
half a year it was unbelievable that was
a different time
i mean look at this the structures man
look i can imagine seeing them in real
life
look how small the people are compared
god damn that's big
i mean you just can't fathom it that's a
big [ __ ] building
and what's crazy is it used to be
covered in smooth limestone
but they these [ __ ] people that uh
built
cairo they pilfered all that [ __ ] yeah
they broke all the chunks off of it to
build other cool things yeah this was a
cool little trip that's morocco i think
no is that what was
uh did you feel safe wandering through
the streets there was it a little
sketchy i didn't do a lot of wandering i
might girl with me also so that's always
like a different
yeah a different thing and it's like uh
yeah i was told i had a guy who i knew
there's a comic
that was out there and he's like i'll
show you around so we did that with the
comic in egypt
well he's a comic in new york shots of
foddy guys
having a hard time getting controversial
jokes to go over
not gonna happen not gonna happen dude
kill you quick
oh yeah yeah yeah we're really lucky
like
oh yeah the [ __ ] we complain that we
can't say is really funny
what do you mean i can't say but you can
you just did see this is the thing
like because we're not on a network
that's controlled by
some sort of uh a business yeah that
worries one way or another
right this business worries when people
aren't controversial
because then the podcasts don't do well
they're born they want chaos
yeah like you know well chaos is the is
the antidote i mean that's the well it's
you know what we're saying you know
we're not talking about people
like if you're if you're on this podcast
you're you're saying things to be funny
right yeah that's what you're doing yeah
if you're making points
you're making interesting points that
you think this is really a valid
valid you know perception of something
that you've
established and there's also talking
[ __ ] that's talking [ __ ] talking [ __ ] is
fun
judge me by my intent not your
interpretation yeah what did i intend to
do
yeah i intend to just [ __ ] make us
laugh exactly that's all it was
that's the problem with banning a word
like [ __ ] like
sometimes it's it's not nice to say it
about someone with a disease
but it's not nice to let someone keep
making youtube videos about the world
being flat either
without saying to them hey man that's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like that's what that is yeah that's
what it is
yeah yeah yeah it's not it's not a
disease it is a slow
form of learning you're slowing learning
yes so we're calling people confusing
people yeah
because people watch those videos and no
one's interrupting you while you're
making those videos
yeah so it can make sense if you're
articulate and smooth and use a lot of
big words you show a lot of faulty
science yeah people can go oh my god
i can't believe all these years i've
been lied to yeah there's a bunch of
people out there you ever look at
hashtag spaces fake
no you want to see a failure of the
american educational system yeah google
hashtag
space is fake and start reading reading
on youtube and instagram
and [ __ ] twitter all these
knuckleheads that really think that
space is fake
right space is fake it's not really the
the moon
it's not really 260 000 miles away or
whatever the [ __ ] it is yeah look
hashtag space is fake
let's say for example there's so many of
them coincidence
let's say for example the world is flat
right let's give them i feel so
dumb but if it is
so what well
i mean you still gotta go talking about
before though about conspiracy theories
about we like them
they're fun you want to solve the puzzle
and if
listen let's be honest most of the
people look there's some people that
just love conspiracy theories yeah but
most of the people that get really
attached
to some of the really dumb ones they
don't they're not doing so well in life
okay they're not they're not they're not
thriving
they're they're they're knuckleheads
yeah and knuckleheads
get attached to these certain kinds of
ideas yeah and then if they can just
prove
that all this is [ __ ] it doesn't
matter how well you're doing
right because the [ __ ] world they've
been lying to us man this whole time
the stars are not really stars they're
lanterns being hung from some ceiling
it's like look man you could you can go
deep on this
and find people that are varying levels
of intelligence
yeah i believe dumber and dumber things
but she'll tap into
some conspiracy stuff right occasionally
yeah yeah what is the thing legit
so what do you what do you go into and
you're like i kind of buy
some of this
i want to know what the deep state
really is
can can we tell them what i texted you
one time which one thing
dude so there's no sports so i have
nothing else so i just start getting
into conspiracy yeah and every time i
think i'm going too far i like text joe
and uh i remember i texted you as i was
like i was like bro what do you think
about this tom hanks as a pedophile
stuff
i think you called me i think you were
so concerned you just called me and
you're like
dude what are you what are you reading
what is going
pump the [ __ ] pranks for whatever
reason on the internet became a thing
to write in tom hanks's comments the
photo that he's a pedophile
dude i don't know what start do you know
what started that
i think it was this pizza i don't know
what happened but someone like sent me
something i get i started going in on it
and then
i remember i came across something that
was like yeah and that's why him and his
wife
rita wilson have uh have coronavirus or
something i was like and i remember
going to you and i was like
is his wife's last name really wilson
and you're like yeah i'm like
like the [ __ ] volleyball like
i'm like what is happening
or we could be in the matrix keep going
we could be in a simulation
if if there is a simulation one day it's
going to be impossible to tell
they're going to get it to a point have
you ever done any vr you ever [ __ ] with
vr dude i bought the sets
ah i saw you got the oculus out there i
got the same one yeah
obsessed it's pretty amazing right it is
the same it's the pyramids
that's the second thing that i saw in my
life the vr headsets for the second
thing i saw was like this makes me
question really yeah
it's crazy dude picking up the things
that's nuts
yeah picking up the fake gun or picking
up the ball throwing it
i watched that alex honold thing you
know the guy who like climbs with no
ropes or whatever
free solo there's a five minute version
you could watch on the vr
and you're up there with him looking
down
it's unreal i can't do that one i get
sweaty hands just watching his videos oh
yeah like watching a youtube video
literally makes my hand start perspiring
i mean i'm afraid of heights big time
he's so
calm he's crazy somebody's off right
he's really nice man super normal like
when you talk to him nothing seems off
at all
no like he seems like a guy who fears
the challenge but like fear receptors or
something like that you know
no because he's had moments he's had
some moments where he's like generally
the only time where you should be
freaked out is when something's going
wrong
he goes most of the time it's really
mellow but he
he climbs this kind of [ __ ] that's too
crazy he's going this way man
yeah he's going up at an angle yeah
it's not it's he's hard to handle but go
deep state
i don't know man i mean we were talking
earlier about george soros videos and
yeah
all these uh these people that think
that someone's pulling the strings from
behind the scenes
you know the more i see crazy [ __ ] like
the jeffrey epstein thing
where um i mean again i didn't i don't
watch much of the documentary because it
was bumming me out yeah
see those 17 year old girls talk about
heavy heavy
yeah and some of them are 11 and 12.
like what heavy 12 year old girls wild
and he was purposely targeting them
but he also had bill clinton fly to his
island 20 times you know he had all
these different people flew on his
planes
he had all these celebrities hillary
flew there
all these scientists all these actors
like what is that
who does that why what what's going on
there like was there some
grand scheme to compromise those people
to get those people
on his side who whose side is his side
you know who worked for him bro he had a
photo of bill clinton in his foyer
of his house yeah it dressed up as uh
with a dress on
like a woman pointing at him like this
like what better way
to say i thought i got you around you i
got you
i own you but my curiosity is this and
this is just from watching
the i watch the thing and again i don't
know a lot a lot of people are saying
right now know way more about this like
anytime i have questions it's either you
or tim dillon
i call up timmy and timmy [ __ ] goes
in tim will go oh he's great
he is if you think what you see in the
videos is any different than him you got
another thing coming
he brought me a book the first time i
met him when he came on the podcast
a book on conspiracy theories he's like
i'm trying to get you back in
dude we're trying to bring you back in
there but that's genuinely him that's
not
this is him unapologetically
authentically him yes
great stuff go check out tim if you guys
haven't um
but he uh he was breaking down some
interesting things with
as far as this goes right i'm just
watching this documentary and it's
blaming everything on epstein and i'm
like okay
this guy's the [ __ ] criminal
mastermind really like he's the
he's the criminal mastermind but he's
doing all the secretarial [ __ ] i can't
i can't believe that right and then they
introduced this other guy
this like les wexner guy the guy that
owns like victoria's secret and that
kind of stuff right yeah and they like
introduce them quick and they kind of
like make it seem
they go uh oh he was actually um
i think i guess epstein was like his
only money manager or something like
that like he managed his wax's money
right
and then there's a clip of western going
you know i was tricked and i was
manipulated and like they have these
other guys going
oh my god epstein's the most
manipulative person in the world he
charms you so much it's really
setting it up like he tricked the
billionaire into giving them tons of
money
at the end of the documentary this girl
maybe you can get this picture up
the girl paints a picture and shows
people right
it's the last episode at the end and she
just painted a picture of her experience
there right in the picture
it's her experience all the things that
were going on all these like [ __ ] up
characters etc
they're talking about the picture and
they use this section where they talk
about epstein right
epstein's off to the right he's on a
[ __ ] ufo he's not even centerfold in
the picture
he's barely in the picture gillen
the girl who's like he's a comet she's
front and center
and then below her i believe is wex
wexner and i'm like that's weird why
would you include
this guy at front and center of the
picture
but this guy over here epstein with this
whole thing he's the criminal mastermind
he's doing all this kind of stuff
is all by himself that's weird hmm
isn't that weird i would have to see him
in the context of her story i don't have
to see it in the context of her story
but yeah it is weird
all of it's weird though just the fact
that there was a [ __ ] island
yeah where is that i mean that's but is
that what they do but imagine if there
was a movie
yeah imagine yeah and in the movie this
guy
would set up these freak parties on
these islands
and uh have all these guys fly in
scientists celebrities and bang 15 year
olds
yeah and film it and hold it against
them
that was the that was the word so here's
but if you saw a movie
you'd be like come on bill clinton's not
going to fly 20 times to a [ __ ]
island that's what makes
this sense he's got girls he can call he
must
yeah he needs it that bad is he really
going to fly this [ __ ] out
but if this guy was intelligence and he
let them think that they're safe
don't worry no one's gonna say a [ __ ]
word everyone's on board
this is fine you can let you freak out
on this island this is like the real
vegas
what happens on [ __ ] island stays on
[ __ ] island this is the real deal
like you could that's what they want
look do you know how many of those guys
in the 60s and the 70s politicians back
then just did openly
openly had affairs right like kennedy
openly
everyone knew it the press all knew it
yeah yeah how many guys were doing that
how many mayors are doing that
i bet a lot of them i bet that's why
they became a doc
a mayor or a [ __ ] president in the
first place
a lot of them wanted power a lot of them
are like these politicians are like
ugly actors they want to be an actor but
they're not good looking enough so they
just pretend to be righteous and they
pretend to be
you know the guy who's going to solve
the mess the guy's going to solve the
problem and
in the meantime they're hobnobbing with
industry and
big bankers and celebrities are coming
to their inauguration
and yeah it's a big there's a big
influence part here it is
someone explained this to me whoa is
that just slain
is that someone who's how do you say it
how do you say your name i thought it
was just slain
so that how is she a lizard so she's the
lizard
but look who's front and [ __ ] center
dude what is going on
look at all the heads well that's a
creepy ass picture
right and where is epstein who's just
take a guess a blue shirt with a
sandwich in his hand
i don't know who's that guy i don't know
john podesta kevin spacey
i don't know look to the right though
no he's in the [ __ ] ufo dude
top right you're telling me the the
criminal mastermind of all this
is is the the [ __ ] supporting act
like
you're in the top right just lane or
glenn why is she a friend center dog and
why does she
have a body of a lizard like how weird
is that she's
got some creepy lizard body i don't know
see this is my point like if you if you
put this in a movie
before all this [ __ ] had happened before
believe it
it would never believe it i'd be like no
one's that [ __ ] manipulative
they can get all these politicians to
just fly to some island and
film them having sex with underage
people and if they did
they'd get caught someone would rat it
out event and then
well they caught him and they brought
him to jail and oh he just died he hung
himself
like what oh well where's the security
cameras
well the security cameras weren't
working it's off
it's off and then no one's talking about
it bro it's just we just get swept away
with the news cycle to do stuff
this is this is the the craziest thing
about the nap scene thing is like
they literally took el chapo right and
put him in that jail
because they're like nah something would
happen to el chapo in mexican jail
right so like we got to put him in jail
where something will definitely not
happen
super top secret security clearance the
best jail the best
the best possible jail and then this guy
just randomly
just like yourself yeah and the security
cameras weren't working
whoops no big deal meanwhile that
michael baden guy the autopsy doctor
from uh
hbo that autopsy series this is a guy
who's
worked on a bunch of high prices he did
the uh george floyd casey yeah
he said the guy was murdered he said the
expectation injuries
well i mean the injuries of no the
epstein injuries were
indicative of being strangled because
the bones in his neck were
i was talking about floyd but yeah yeah
yeah we did that as well yep
um more doctors have done that as well
with floyd now with george ford more
doctors
it's clear you just watch it you can't
you can't imagine a world where that's
not a homicide
it's so [ __ ] up the epstein thing it
was too low on his neck
it wasn't indicative of someone who was
strangled it was indicative
or it wasn't indicative of someone hung
themselves yeah it was indicative of
someone who was strangled it was low on
the neck
like the guy's behind him pulling his
[ __ ] neck with a wire
or a rope or some [ __ ] question for you
do you think they tell them yo
we got the underage shorties on the
island come through or do you think they
say
everyone here is over rich don't worry
about everything's good then they got it
videotaped
and they're like by the way they're all
underage i think
that's more the case i think if i had to
guess the most nefarious version of it i
doubt
there's people sitting around going hey
do you want to bang underage girls
i think they probably say hey we have
we're going to have this party it's on
an island no one's going to be there but
us
it's fantastic it's top top shelf
accommodations we have girls there
they're lovely maybe they don't even
tell them they have girls there i guess
they probably tell them to have girls
that's how they get them there hey you
want to grow out hey you want a problem
you guys want to go fishing hey come on
bro we have some jet skis dude it's
going to be
coconut milk trust me um and
i think once they get them there they
get them drinking and then once they're
drinking
it's they start partying there's the
island man right so i think they start
partying
and then the girls were probably either
paid to
or trained to be friendly to them
and uh i mean the men are probably
disgusting
and you got a guy like clinton i mean
that guy
i mean he would [ __ ] a warm jar of
peanut butter
he's an animal you
i mean know an animal right right right
my [ __ ] brain is this is what happens
when you're a comic and you're just
trying to think about
the different angle all day when you
said [ __ ] a warm jar of peanut butter
i'm like what would be the best
condiment to [ __ ]
peanut butter would it be peanut butter
what would it be jam you need something
thick and
something you're not going to get
you know what you want you want organic
peanut butter because you gotta stir it
this is why you got to open up the
comedy clubs bro
because otherwise we would talk about
[ __ ] people
just open them up but clinton has always
been known to be a wild man
yeah he [ __ ] everything he tries to
[ __ ] girls and they they yell and they
scream and they run away
yeah he's got women that have said he
raped them i mean he's a [ __ ]
animal yeah i would imagine you get that
guy alone
on an island get a couple of drinks it's
going down and
then epstein is connected to these
people who assure you
don't worry everything's covered this is
how we do it like look the world's too
there's too much scrutiny out there okay
bill you got to be yourself okay
so here's my question this wasn't
always scrutinized right you got songs
[ __ ] rolling stones don't they have a
song talking about banging some 15 year
old girl or something like that
i believe there's a song right look it
up rolling song
you have you have songs about people
talking kiss had a song called christine
16.
dude every movie in the 80s only 17
17. remember that i'm just saying
every movie in the 80s they were like
high school seniors and then like where
the freshmen
at yes right they're 14 year olds
granted you're all in high school but
you still maybe would have college kids
like for whatever okay
so there was a time where it was
probably
okay right to sleep with younger women
right i'm not talking about the 11 and
12. i'm talking about teenage women it
was probably okay
okay at that time how did they
compromise people because if we really
want to know who's behind this
just figure out what they were doing
before the
pedophile stuff because yeah but they
controlled the press like before that no
one could say anything about it so
you're saying they didn't
need to compromise back in the day and
then they they were like well [ __ ] we
need to find a way to compromise
little kids okay exactly exactly i feel
like you always had a compromise you
always had to have something on someone
like
you don't think that you don't think
that i don't think so
no no you don't think it's like
coincidental that like you know maybe
clinton had some [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
happened in arkansas and they're like
all right we're gonna get you out of
that but
you know you're gonna you're gonna keep
on you're gonna have an interesting
political career just look out for your
boys
i don't think so i mean i don't think
they had
film footage of it and i think they
controlled the media
but you know the clinton stuff goes way
back um i don't know you know the mina
arkansas [ __ ]
no no clinton was the governor of
arkansas when barry seals was running
cocaine through mena arkansas
he would go to south america and there's
always footage there's a great movie
about it with tom cruise
that's the yes that's about barry seal
okay
and that was a real guy who was a pilot
yeah fly back with coke
and they would drop the coke off in mina
arkansas
okay they dropped the coke off and these
two kids found it they found the drop
they murdered these two kids and they
said the kids committed suicide this kid
the kids were doing drugs
they fell asleep on the train tracks
yeah they just made this [ __ ] up right
so when they uh were k
when they did the autopsy on the kids
and they said oh the kids died of
suicide they
they got high and they slept on the
train tracks the parents are like that's
not our kids
their kids would not do that so they do
a separate autopsy
separate independent autopsy and they
find knife wounds in these kids
bro so the kids have been murdered it
gets worse so then
barry seals agrees to uh sell everybody
out
so he agrees to testify he is on his way
to the courtroom
with george bush's phone number in his
[ __ ] pocket when he's gunned down in
his car yeah he's assassinated
on his way to testify a guy who's a
absolute and also in the movie the tom
cruise movie
they showed bill clinton pardoning him
he got caught for something
bill clinton parted him whoa what if
yeah what if compromising people
saves their life what if back in the day
you're like yo if you talk i'm gonna
kill you actually i think you're gonna
talk
you're dead like that's what the mafia
does right they're like you're gonna
snitch we're killing you any gangs
whatever you're gonna decision is we're
gonna kill you
but what if their technique is like dude
i'm tired of killing people you're gonna
[ __ ] some kids or you're gonna do
something that you do not want getting
out there yes you better not tell
yes but you gotta think a guy like
they're prominent big-time politician
they know so much [ __ ] about so many
people and so many different things that
are wrong yeah so many different things
that are illegal so get him to [ __ ] her
kid
you got to wonder about anthony weiner
keep going
anthony weiner was the guy that was
showing that dang
he was showing that day yeah and he was
uh married
did you see it not too distracted i
didn't look at his [ __ ] heard is a good
because he's
a good sized [ __ ] i look at a famous
dick look he's a [ __ ]
bold man and he is an amazing speaker
okay
yeah yeah and they were worried about
him they were thinking this [ __ ]
could be a big
time politician so we need to compromise
his so they i don't know
whether he was just a freak or whether
this is how he's always been
yeah and this is his kink but he likes
sexting with underage girls
bad so they put him in [ __ ] jail for
it bad but here's what's interesting
about it
the very laptop that he was using
to sex with these underage girls also
has hillary clinton's emails on it like
that was part of the problem like his
wife was communicating with hillary
clinton joe we need what is this
we need a yeah let's get to that i just
had it right fbi communication of
discovery of hillary clinton emails on
anthony weiner's laptop computer
so so they they found her
important emails on the laptop that he's
using
to sext with these underage girls to
have these messages
look i'm not saying he didn't do it
because i think he did
because he sent pictures of him with his
dick you can't
i think he's a freak and i think like i
said they're they're
ugly actors they're people who are ugly
the two i think the guy is a comic
that's what i think who wiener meaner
weiner yeah i mean
he's he's a comic just nobody ever
taught him how to do comedy yeah
so he just expressed his freakitude in
terrible
awful ways but there's a picture of him
he's got his phone up like this
yeah he's got his hog like half hard in
his underwear
lying there and i think he was like
lying with one of his kids
that's foul it's crazy that's weird
sending these to girls just a
willy-nilly
do you know how nuts that is that he
just doesn't even know these gals
so maybe he was just a sex addict maybe
he was a
sexting addict with underage girls see
there's a picture of his hog
and his kid asleep see right there right
there question
and now you got me on this [ __ ]
rabbit hole look at those selfies
no no i see it but go back to go by the
look at the upper left-hand corner
like he was a freak okay it's not like
he's getting roped in he was a freak he
was clearly
a freak there was something about him
that was a freak
but also i mean sexting with a 15 year
old did he know she was 15.
that's the other question did he was he
aware of the ability
who knows yeah or maybe that's a picture
he said to his wife
kill him wait what who knows
that's what they do but maybe that's a
picture he sent to his wife and they're
like now we're going to send that to a
15 year old because now we got your
laptop we could do whatever
and then we got some worse [ __ ] on you
and you're going to take this little
charge right here before we tell you
what we're really up to
he was very bombastic and very
argumentative
in the senate and he would yell and
scream and the senator is out of order
the senator would yield the floor and he
he had this way of talking
very powerful speaker jamie he knew
he knew yeah i don't want to we don't
need to get into this but i don't want
to know i don't know that's gross
yeah okay maybe there's a culture of
these creepy guys
doing this [ __ ] to younger girls in in
in politics yeah there's a culture of
that maybe he's an example
of that culture yeah it's like it's not
that like
it's not like politics makes you do that
it's right politics has something that
is um enticing to those type of people
which is obviously power it's like yes
it's like the catholic church doesn't
make you
touch kids but if you did want to touch
kids and you want some smoke screen
okay here's a perfect is a perfect
situation yeah
you know what i mean yeah i do know what
you mean like i don't think that i don't
think catholicism makes you do that
but if you did want to do it that would
be the perfect place to go
i think the one of the ways that
catholicism does do that
is you go there when you're young and
you get molested
and then you think that that's normal
right right remember you start molesting
other kids
right right that is a one thing that
does happen to people who get molested
there's
there's not just a high rate of them
molesting other there's a high
recidivism rate
yeah but there's a very high rate of
them molesting people as well
yes that's one of the horrible it's like
almost like like you're
a vampire when you do that to some kids
it's like you put it in them
and then they go out and perpetrate the
same evil that was done to them
that's a good way of putting it it is
like that in a way because
you hear all these stories about guys
who molest kids
who were molested yeah but
you know so i don't i think there's this
is sickness when someone wants to [ __ ] a
15 year old
even if you want to text them and
pretend you want to [ __ ] a 15 year old
yeah
especially a guy with kids yeah it's
just yeah it's just so [ __ ]
but how many of them were there like i i
told you about that breitbart
podesta yeah we talked about that yeah
like that's a crazy quote yeah i don't
know if it's true
i don't know what the [ __ ] if do you
believe it
i don't know what to believe and this is
after all this
here jamie i'm going to send you this
i'm going to air drop this to you i'll
just text it to you
hold on one second i'm peeing go pee
all right we're back and we're back
let's pee feel better oh dude so much
anyway so we're talking about creeps and
people want to [ __ ] kids
yeah here this is a this is a thing that
andrew breitbart
tweeted in 2011 before he died how proud
guru john podesta isn't household name
as world-class underage sex slave op
cover upper defending unspeakable dregs
escapes me
right now what does that mean what does
that mean
um maybe breitbart's crazy
maybe he's crazy i would have thought
all these crazy people die
randomly it's kind of weird right right
after they accuse people
isn't that crazy so that's so crazy but
you know what it's like
tom hanks wife being named rita wilson
dude
it's just a coincidence it's just a
coincidence dude you know what before
i mean you got to do you had to do a bit
about it but you were saying how like uh
there's no more crazy
right we're just talking about just
random things and you're like what
happened is just crazy and back in the
day maybe we put
too many things under the umbrella of
crazy right
maybe and yeah maybe back way back in
the day when it was just anybody who was
like you're left-handed you're [ __ ]
crazy like right
right yeah yeah and now we don't put
enough
in crazy well we there's certain things
that we exempt from
possibility of crazy but this is
something we always allow is crazy
right like yeah oh that's crazy right
it's like that's crazy that can't be
real yep yep
if you call out somebody and you end up
getting murked and you're like maybe
there's a coincidence going on there
what are you
crazy yeah you must be insane to think
well there's a bunch of those man that's
when
seth rich got murdered everybody was
worried about that what's that
seth rich he was the guy that supposedly
according to wikileaks he gave them the
information on the dnc
being corrupt and rigging the vote with
uh oh with hillary with hillary clinton
they were uh
they conspired against bernie sanders
yeah that's when donna brazile wrote
about it in her book when seth rich was
murdered
she got really scared right and she was
a top operative
what do you think what if we sat down
with the deep state right or the powers
be whoever's
doing all this like a kid [ __ ] what
would they look like yeah what
would the deep state look like um oh
that's a good question i don't know
dude like who are they who are they dude
and how do you get the job and like how
do you like move up in it like all right
like you've been really deep bro we want
to give you a raise
hey dude you've been going deep dude
yeah
how do you is it bankers is it all like
no-name bankers that none of us
know who they are i went on a [ __ ] it
was bad
did you go to a rabbit hole i went on
there's this guy named bill still
please interview bill still oh no he
back in the day did this documentary i
don't know if it was like pbs or
something like that it was just about
the banking institutions and how they've
been controlling
every policy decision back into the
1700s and then before that in europe
and how these few banking families have
all kind of worked together and
anybody who criticizes the banks and try
to break breaks up the banks
they're remembered poorly in history i
believe that like andrew jackson for
example like he
got rid of the fed like he killed the
banks yeah and he's remembered he has
the worst reputation of the president
right oh he's that racist president like
all the other presidents had slaves but
andrew jackson
he was really racist about it yeah dude
this guy bill still so i get this
i'll send you a link i'll get i mean it
probably only has like 40 000 views but
it was for television it was on like
some sort of you know
i don't know what is pbs just like uh
regular
what is broadcasting channel one
but but uh but yeah and i just watched
it
and i was like oh this is really
fascinating just like learning about
money learning about like fraction
fractional reserve lending and just like
these interesting
interesting things like make the economy
go and like how it works you find out
that the bilderberg group is real
you're like wait what the bilderberg
group is the group that uh
get together oh the jekyll island thing
well that is isn't that how the irs was
formed isn't that czech
boy we're so dumb no currency there was
something about
the the yeah he basically makes long
island as a different he makes this
correlation where
any president who tried to create
currency that wasn't dependent on the
banks
got murked and then i go and i'm looking
at this i'm like
yeah lincoln what did lincoln do they
can do that and then he goes you know
why her money's green
because in the civil war he went to the
banks and asked for a loan for the civil
war and they were like it's going to be
20 25
interest on the loan he was like nah
[ __ ] i'm printing my own [ __ ] the
greenbacks
well really and then some [ __ ] actor
shoots him why would an actor care about
slavery
like you're some theater nerd you're
some theater dork
come on dude doesn't it seem weird i
know i'm getting really conspiratorial
but like yeah but you're allowed to with
lincoln
it's like it's long enough ago it
doesn't matter right you can get away
with that you're telling me
just imagine a theater nerd let's go
like who's the biggest theater nerd
right now like give me an oswald there's
a there's another interesting time
john wilkes booth brother was also a
famous actor in new york
yeah and i think it was the week before
lincoln was killed
he saved his son from getting hit by a
car
randomly as though that's a random
occurrence
and this is back in the day there was
barely any cars fun fact on the boosters
yeah
there was no cars back in the day let me
double check that i think yeah
it's wild though right yeah so check
this guy bills to i don't even know if
he's still alive i don't think he got
murked
but like he's just he was really
passionate about it he's really
passionate about like breaking the bank
and not having you know ourselves be
like tied to these banking institutions
that like dictate monetary policy well
wasn't that a part of kennedy as well
where's katie assassination he wanted to
get rid of the federal reserve
everyone that wants to get rid of it and
if they get close adios
bro it's with the way he puts it who
else got shot uh
oh he got shot jackson he got shot but
he lived um
reagan he got shot by a psycho
but they're all psychos they're all
crazy yes
they're all crazy when they need to be
crazy oh well you got to read this book
called chaos
go oh my god oh my god it's about
charles manson right it starts out about
charles manson wasn't he
wasn't he like a oh yeah cia and then
yeah
yeah he was he was a prisoner who they
gave acid to
and they trained him how to do that to
other people so he took these
impressionable youths yeah and dosed him
up with acid yeah and then he would like
pretend he was taking it
and he would guide them and tell him
what to do and then he had him go out
and murder people so
and every time he got arrested they let
him out of jail he's a guy named tom
o'neill who started his book
yeah he started his book as a story that
he was writing for premier magazine
right but as he dug deeper and deeper
into the case he was like what the [ __ ]
is going on
yeah well how about this yeah there's a
free clinic oh we're going in
free clinic in haiti ashbury the cia
operated under
with this program where they were they
were doing tests on people yeah
doing tests on hippies and giving them
assets until his book comes out
his book comes out three months after
his book comes out
the clinic goes out of business this is
a clinic that had been in operation for
50 [ __ ] years
yeah yeah it's a tricky
dude it's a tricky thing right it's like
my girl said something interesting to me
she you know because there's all these
like serial killer documentaries on like
um
on netflix all that kind of stuff right
yeah and and i'm like
like are there serial killers in other
places like why do we just have it here
like or do they have it in london do
they have it in like
paris like the ripper well jack the
ripper right and then like after that i
don't think there was a lot of ribbon
right like i think like he did it and
then there's no more ribbon i don't know
and then i'm like and then she goes this
and she just goes honestly i think it
was all the acid
and i go what do you mean she goes well
they're doing all these drugs in the 60s
and 70s and also in the 80s they just
start like
tearing through women and they're just
all these serial killers that pop up out
of nowhere and i'm like
holy [ __ ] well you know what the people
they experimented on
ted kaczynski the unabomber and they
didn't talk about this in the
netflix documentary of course netflix
documentary they kind of
briefly touched upon that about drugs
they they use the the
just the random word drugs yeah or the
um
blanket word drugs yeah but he was a
part of the harvard uh lsd experiments
yeah he was a part of these uh these and
he
they talked about the psychological
experiments they did where they were
breaking him down for three years
but he was already a little loony to
begin with and then they [ __ ] with him
for three years and probably
force-fed them acid they did it to a lot
of people
there was a thing called operation
midnight climax they did back then
where they would they would run [ __ ]
houses they would run whorehouses
but they're not even hiding it it's the
most obvious
name for the bucket well the other one
was mk ultra um that's the one i heard
about
mind control experiments yeah but a part
of mk ultra was operation midnight
climax
and they did this in san francisco as
well the same people
um that were involved in that clinic
were also involved and they would
make these brothels and then they would
hire these ladies to come in and have
sex with these guys
and they would dose the guys up with
acid so these guys would go in thinking
they're going to
just get some sex then they got the
greatest sex a drink
and they'd be on acid just tripping
their balls off and then they would just
run experiments on these [ __ ] guys
what are you gonna do tell people
you know tell people you went to a
whorehouse you got drugged really is
that what happened
is that what happened really so here's
my question to you let's say that we're
in charge of like
nation building or whatever it is like
let's say we're deep state right deep
state
and we are tasked with keeping america
on top
by any means necessary this is a good
argument okay
yeah you and i right our families
our kids everything is dependent on us
developing
the coolest well i don't want to use the
term cool but most effective
weapons of manipulation to maintain
our status in the world and because of
that we get to live the lives that we
get to live
and if we don't do it there are other
countries that are doing the exact same
thing
and the second we slip they're gonna
body us right
would you go so far would you go so far
as to do these types of things
the right answer is obviously no but if
you knew the exact same experiment was
happening in china right now
and the second they figured it out they
were going to find ways to manipulate
the powers to be and then the next trip
a polit
politician ends up in china all of a
sudden they get doused with some [ __ ]
now they're controlled i don't know
exactly how they are argument to accept
some sort of uh new world order
or accept some sort of a tolterra
totalitarian regime
that controls the people the same way
china controls the people because
otherwise we can't compete with them
keep going china has this connection
between the big businesses and
corporations in china and the military
and the government
they're all connected it's one thing
there's not two things
it's not like you have a business and
then there's the government no your
business is a part of the government
if you're wanting huawei you are hand in
hand with the chinese government
the only way the united states is going
to compete is if we
run things over here the way they run
things over there because
they can cut corners take chances they
have mass surveillance on their people
that way it keeps things running
smoother
and there's oh well they also have covet
tracking we need to track you
we need to track you put a chat business
put a chip in your hands not a chip we
don't need a chip you got your phone you
ain't leaving that alone yeah that's
right
they never you never needed a chip
exactly you don't need a chip
just give get him addicted to a game
question
don't you think we right that's chinese
government chinese government yeah
i've been killing it with tick-tock
faces well i'm not gonna lie i gotta
show you i got some good ones
but uh uh okay here's the thing
don't you think we're already there and
let me let me clarify
okay do you really think google
isn't sitting down with the u.s
government and the u.s government isn't
going and we're gonna need access to all
that i mean
we'll pretend like you guys are
operating by yourself but you all know
what time it is
well for sure they do and google's
actually sat down with the chinese
government
and the argument of censoring over there
was that if we don't
they're just gonna steal our
intellectual property and just remake
google in a chinese forum we need to
work with them
well you don't need to do anything
google you want to work with them no no
we need to
we need to we don't have enough money
because what we don't have we need more
we need more money i just think i wonder
that even
like with elon even with elon it's like
you you reach a certain level you
must have look if i'm the guy if i'm
deep state right and i would know we got
this smart south african dude
right and he can invent anything he can
do all this cool [ __ ]
and i'm gonna be like all right yeah
bring him over here and he's like well
maybe i want to go you know sell some
[ __ ] to saudi arabia and i'll be like
maybe you don't
right yeah and he's like yeah just as
simple as that
he's like i'm going to go on joe rogan's
podcast and smoke weed you're like do
whatever the [ __ ] you want we don't care
about the stock prices
i just i just wonder if if if the r if
the
if the exchange is hey we need some cool
rockets
we need some great [ __ ] and if you have
any ideas
throw them our way first what what are
those network deals first right of
refusal development
no not development remember like first
right of refusal it's a yo if you build
some [ __ ] this fire we look at it first
if we don't like it sell to saudi arabia
but we'll look at it we got it first
and if we ever need some real dope [ __ ]
you make it now what is the exchange
if you want to keep your factory open
during covet you get to do that
i think he's got so much influence and
they realize that their law was stupid
this this it was stupid but most places
are still closed and he was like yo i'm
staying open and then the government was
like all right you stand open
why are you standing up because i need
to make california state government
because other governments were allowing
him to open
so this is not deep state [ __ ] this is
like a state to state thing because he
could have that much influence
hey y'all come on over here by all means
yeah yeah and we have oil yeah and we'll
still let you do it
there are states that were willing to
let him rock and roll
but wouldn't you do that wouldn't you do
that with like a bezos like wouldn't you
go
hey guys operate i guess what i'm trying
to say is like
there's like this structure in america
right where at the bottom you have no
power
and it [ __ ] sucks and you're just
barely surviving you make some money
you're good your life is good but you're
still attached to your job you need to
do that in order to survive
you get into like the millions 10
million 100 millions right
and you actually have freedom and the
second you get into the billions
you get a knock on the door where it's
like you got a lot
you got a lot of stuff and we're gonna
need to
have some conversations about how you
use that stuff and the people you talk
to and the deals that you do
because you got too much power like i'm
shocked like
for years i've been shocked even with
this platform i'm like how is there one
guy
that can speak to the whole world and
the us government isn't [ __ ]
surveilling you and they're having
drones everywhere
watch the show it's like anyone can get
it oh that's a good point
you're not hiding no that's the
it's like there's freedom in in uh
exposing yes
you can really be free if you just give
also i'm a [ __ ]
cage fighting commentator dude what if
you're deep state that was really your
smoke screen
imagine if you just got really good at
these things just so you could be deep
state
you the problem is that's not how people
get good at things
right you get things from no motivation
you'd never be able to compete with guys
really hustling yeah you have to be
really hustling
and then they bring you to [ __ ] island
they give videos
do you think i have a question about mma
for you okay
why do we keep hearing about the
underpaying stuff
well right now in particular um there's
probably less money because the fighters
have
to um there's no gate there's no live
gate yeah there's no live gate and
that's an extreme
amount of money but there's also
fighters that agreed to certain deals
they agreed to like an eight fight deal
x amount per fight
and then they become more popular and
then they want to renegotiate their deal
yeah and the ufc is like look we're just
trying to stay open yep
we're not going to renegotiate anything
so they're like maybe take it or you can
leave it but this is what it is
yeah i think it's a matter of that but
looking at it from the fighter's
perspective fighters would be
certainly better off if there was more
competition that's always how it works
yep so whether it's bellator or 1fc
or all these different companies the
more of those there are the more
world series of fighting the moral
professional fighting league whatever
the [ __ ] it's called now
the more those rise the better it is for
everyone it's just how it is it's like
if there's only improvs
and then you get banned from the improvs
you're [ __ ] but if you've got funny
bones if you've got some theaters
yes yes it's exactly like that you know
i've seen that happen before with people
yeah i've seen that happen with comedy
clubs and i've seen that happen with
fighting too you get banned from a big
organization and then you're [ __ ] man
nobody
like it's not a monopoly in that you do
have cho
you do have choices but there's one
clear top of the food chain
choice but it's because they do it the
best they're also the only ones that are
having fights
during this quarantine the only people
that are putting on any live sporting
events it's amazing
but they're also a part of a company in
wme that's
hurting and needs it yeah really bad
so there's not a lot of money to throw
around
like to keep the doors open to keep
people employed
a lot of money is uh is
is missing right yeah all these shows
got cancelled
yeah there's all these uh audience
members that aren't going to be there
buying tickets and
so it's tricky man so this is why i
think they're complaining about
fighter pay i think they should get paid
more right
i think everybody should get paid more
it's a crazy way to make a living
i think you should get the most amount
of money you can possibly get yep
but it's also a business and i think
that if they are
struggling as much as i think they are i
don't talk
finances with them but i know that wme
people own it
yeah they're hurt yeah bad they're
laying people off
yep most businesses are hurting it's
in all the entertainment business is
[ __ ] live nation's [ __ ]
yeah right all these people are [ __ ]
yeah big time so what do they do
that's what i think but yeah you know
when it comes to me as a as a human that
likes fighting
i i know how [ __ ] dangerous that [ __ ]
is you should get paid an incredibly
generous amount of money to step into a
cage fight for millions of people to see
yeah yeah it is interesting because you
have um
you have this situation where like the
quality
of the fights is undeniably better
because it's not in the free market you
have people that are really good
at picking out fights and for the most
part i say this as a boxing fan right so
i grew up in boxing where there are
tons of different divisions or tons of
different companies if you want
wbc wbo all these promoters different
promoters
and sometimes they do sometimes they
don't right but like it's a mess
and then sometimes what happens is you
have guys who are like really boring
fighters
but they get a position where they have
the belt and then
it actually hurts the sport in a way but
they earned it and they deserve it
so as like a sportsman i'm like they
deserve to have it
like a lot of people i love floyd
mayweather i think he's the best
fighter in the history of fighting right
i think he's actually one of the
greatest
people at their job ever like i think
he's michael jordan
of boxing he's one of the without a
doubt one of the greatest boxers if not
the greatest boxer that has ever lived
it's he's on 50 you know but he for
average people
fought born for me i loved it but for
absolute thought it was boring so he
needed the antics
yeah he needed to get people angry at
him yeah
right and it works but the thing is with
the ufc is i'll watch guys i don't
[ __ ]
know and i'll enjoy it
and i feel like i don't know if that's
just because of the sport but also
because of the way that they're matching
the fighters and it's not specifically
hey you're ranked here you're ranked
here we have to match you
part of it is you're ranked here you're
right here but also your styles would
make something interesting
so i wonder if it's correct no do you
think it's better to not be
completely free market do you think it's
better to have the fights
for the quality of the sport if you're a
fan
it's certainly better for you right if
the fighters
get if they all get together in one
organization
and then that organization makes them
fight each other that way there's
not as many dream matchups you never get
to see right
like one of the things that everybody
got upset was by the time floyd fought
manny pacquiao
it was like past manny's prime and manny
had a bum shoulder and all these
different things yeah we would have
liked to see that fight
five years earlier and in the ufc that
fight gets made
easily yeah it gets made but it gets to
a situation where a guy like jon jones
says hey i've got a contract for light
heavyweight fights but
uh you know would he want to give me the
fight francis and gano because i want a
lot of [ __ ] money because that guy's
terrifying yeah and uh they say you get
what you're paid in your contract that's
what you get
and he's like well i'm not fighting then
and they go okay
it is interesting see that's one of
those situations where i don't know
who's right or who's wrong because
i don't know how much money they would
make for that if there's no audience
let's say that francis ingano fights a
big fight and it gets like
500 000 pay-per-view 600 700 000
pay-per-views that's a lot of
pay-per-views yep
um live gate how much in the whole are
they
how much money how much money in the
whole are they
right how much how hard is it to make
money right now how much can you afford
how much do they make i don't know these
answers yeah how much do they make for a
pay-per-view were
seven hundred thousand buys a million
buyers do they make
how much what's the overhead i mean
i don't know it's less but it's not i
mean it has to be less because you're
not maintaining these venues the venue's
so much smaller you have to pay way less
people
that being said the ticket prices like
the live gate
glove gate's big 20 000 people 18 000
people all spending on average 150
a ticket and on top of that there's
merch there's all sorts of [ __ ] there's
you know i'm sure they probably get some
sort of a food piece of all that stuff
yeah so there's a lot of and then
there's also they had to operate
they didn't fire anybody it's one thing
about the ufc they would not fire people
so they stayed open wouldn't wouldn't
fire anybody
while they were going on for months just
paying people trying to figure out how
to put this together and make fights
happen
they tried to do that one at the indian
place uh tai chi palace in lamar
california
they got real close to doing that but
then the [ __ ] governor got a hold of
the head of disney and eisner and they
called
dana white and they told them pull out
pull out okay so they back out of that
and then two weeks later
florida's like come on in so then we do
one in florida
with no audience a little bit and then
finally they're allowing us to do them
at the apec center
in vegas and i think right now it's a
triage
right now they're trying to stop the
bleeding and the japanese is wmed
like wme and the ufc the ufc is
operating with full costs
for months right with without any money
coming in at all
so you have to think that yeah that's
right yeah it's like wme i think
like paid four billion or something for
them or something a little more than
that so they have this
giant monthly nut they have to have to
cover cover every month
and people i guess don't realize is like
an agency makes money off of the
commission of their clients
and if their clients can't work because
of corona
the agency has no revenue coming in none
zero there's no tv
i guess there's some tv shows getting
made but like
still they're not they're not doing
production on like films or anything
like that yeah
no yeah it is interesting
well they're start they're starting to
do uh films next week
they are it's coming back what was your
thoughts
someone gets sick and then you're liable
that's the tricky thing it's like
they don't want god forbid somebody ends
up one of these like
nba coaches who's old god forbid greg
popovich who's [ __ ] 70.
oh yeah gets corona death
it is and now you want to be the nba
commissioner that killed gregg pompovich
oh my god or be um a ufc promoter
that you a fighter gets sick goes home
and kills his mom who works with him
you know maybe your mom helps cook for
you your mom gets sick
maybe your mom's helping you in camp
your mom gets sick and dies from corona
because
they had the fights
i don't think that's going to happen and
i think particularly now when you're
hearing these reports of
the cases diminishing the the viral load
that they're
finding like in italy is so small yeah
it's barely detectable
yeah you know the the hope is that same
[ __ ] happens here as it gets hot out
that italy thing was so funny
why is it funny it's cause like they
said that
the the symptoms of corona were like you
couldn't taste and smell
and italy was like the first country
there was it's a pandemic
like everybody inside we can't eat we
can't taste pasta we gotta get a
bottle of wine we can't smell great food
exactly
and then people in sweden which has like
trash cuisine anyway and they're just
like yeah let it rip
give us a [ __ ] what did the english say
we're gonna take it on the chin
right what are we living for anyway yeah
our food tastes like [ __ ]
swedish meatballs they are good
meatballs they do
they do and then there's all this
concern that they're doing it wrong and
they're doing it right we need to watch
sweden
look sweden's fine why can't we do it
like sweden no the death rate is very
high
the death toll all of it
was it high comparatively
i think it's higher i think letting it
burn through the city
is comparatively higher right i think
the question is
what would you rather have would you
rather have the freedom to decide for
yourself
and and know that there's some risks
involved
yeah or would you rather have the
government lock everything down
save people's lives from now but then
the economy crashes and
you know for every the unemployment rate
there's some sort of a some sort of a
graph that they use or some sort of a an
equation but for every percentage the
unemployment rate
goes up more people are unemployed x
amount of people die
that's a that's a fact they know that
roughly yeah and
this is not taken into account at all
the deaths that we're looking at are
only the deaths due to disease
yeah that's why you know it's been
politicized because the
politicians aren't going to be
accountable for the deaths because of
unemployment because they could blame it
on the pandemic
but they will be responsible for the
deaths
from corona if they're opening up too
early dude they should have quarantined
sick people
and high-risk people people that are ill
illnesses pre-existing conditions old
people people that are vulnerable we
could have done that that could have
been done
if if all these people right that have
gone out and marched
right i mean like just yesterday we were
at a march in santa barbara right we're
in the crowd
right we're talking to folks like do you
think if nobody ends up getting corona
or the numbers don't spike that high
we'll forever lose or at least for our
lives lose faith
in what our public health sector tells
us
we need to be concerned about i think
already people are losing faith
but especially after this right now like
this is initially yeah especially but i
think people have already
when they find out how many people
actually got it versus how many people
died versus what they thought
how many people are going to get it
versus how many people i mean it's a
tiny fraction they can't
they keep trying to scare us have you
seen the image of downtown l.a yesterday
it was it's wild yeah it's an overhead
view we could see 50 000 people filling
the street
it's crazy yeah they don't get it nobody
has it it's not real
it's not you're going to get a call bro
you're going to get a call from the fbi
i wonder what the numbers are going to
be man in two weeks i mean are we going
to have a
sharp increase in deaths yeah two weeks
because of these
these uh protests dude you know how i
knew that i wasn't taking it seriously
because like for the first maybe
two weeks i wash my hands after i peed
and then after a while you're like man
i'm good bro
like just just right now i only washed
my hand i actually walked out and i
realized you were still in there and you
were like
yeah that's a classic guy move but
that's how i knew it wasn't i was like
whatever dude
but that doesn't make any sense what if
it was the play what do you mean
what if it really was real what if it
really was something it takes like 17 18
days and
it's super contagious and everybody gets
it 17 18 days and you're just deathly
ill
everybody no matter who you are that's
nothing to do with your immune system
stop it with your health privilege yeah
it has to do only with this
people that's what i just said i just
made it up health privilege health
privilege well that's what it is they're
shaming you for health privilege right
right stay home save lives yeah ima look
at that that's downtown l.a
oh yeah imagine if this really was just
a political ploy
to crush the economy and that they knew
it wasn't going to be that bad they knew
it was going to be bad but it didn't
require
shutting everything down for months and
months at a time but it's a good thing
to do if you want to
kill the economy start civil unrest
let's go deep state theory right deep
state
dave's hate theory uh pull the strings
you know you can't let biden debate
right because it's going to be a
massacre not good
um i got hairy legs
did you see the uh you see the clip it
was great what the [ __ ] are you saying
that's just a wild dude so you don't
want him to debate right
and whose power is actually public
appearance
whose rallies trump so now you take away
the ability the ability to go out those
big rounds
do those rallies which are incredibly
persuasive
if you're someone who's on the fence and
you limit
the liability that is biden in a
potential debate where he could have
these gaffes etc
then on top of it you have civil unrest
and you blame it all in him
but here's the thing you could see how
it all played out
that guy is just a piece of [ __ ] in
minneapolis yeah he's not some deep
state player who chalvin
yeah uh derek johnson a piece of [ __ ]
yeah just a piece of [ __ ] yeah
and he killed that guy we all saw it and
he's got a long history
it's not like he started out as a
corrupt cop really is just a deep state
long player so in 2006
they brought him in as a manchurian
candidate we're going to let you marry a
hot asian we're going to let you marry
miss minnesota you know his wife was
miss minnesota yeah yeah
she's hot as [ __ ] that's the payment she
dropped him though immediately
that's how you know it's set up deep
state so set up deep state
dude it's set up deep and then they're
gonna say you imagine you can't say he's
a white supremacist he's
an asian wife that's true good call what
what is that thing that they do what is
it called when someone's a sleeper when
they wait for a long time before they
they act causes no no no no no no
no when someone is like they they
they're undercover for a long time
and then manchurian candidate wasn't no
but that's the manchurian candidate
someone's been hypnotized
the the thing is like a sleeper cell
like someone who doesn't
they don't do anything for acting as a
normal citizen and they just wait
and then like all right we're getting
close to the election get in there
go kill a guy and there's a young girl's
going to film you
yeah you're going to kill her anyway i
mean kill him anyway
yeah the girl was filming him 17 year
old girl filming him with her camera a
17 year old girl got the george floyd
video
yeah there was a lot of people out there
wasn't there well there was a 17 year
old girl's video that we all saw
interesting yeah 17 year old girl and a
lot of people were giving her
a hard time because she didn't you do
something a [ __ ]
cop a 17 year old girl a grown man is
killing another grown
yeah yeah yeah you want her to step in
really yeah it's
it is deep state what it's all a long
game it's 4d chess
what are your thoughts on what has
transpired since
look that gives me hope when i see 50
000 people walking through downtown l.a
all all peacefully protesting that gives
me hope
there's a real chance for a real shift
yep a real shift
but it's also here's the thing that bugs
me yeah
all that money they came with to bail
out
all these corporations from the
coronavirus the pandemic why couldn't
they have used that money already to
bail out these inner cities
why couldn't they have find the money to
to
they have all these cities that have
this systemic
crime and violence and racism that's
been going on forever
forever a place like baltimore yeah that
are directly
[ __ ] up as a result of racist
practices and selling houses
and they don't do anything to fix that
they never they never try to stop where
the crime is coming from yeah they never
try to make the
those cities better they never try to
add community centers
and figure out a way to to do something
whether
there's no nothing on the table it's
just crime-ridden neighborhoods
just how they are like forever yeah
crime doesn't matter until it affects
the pockets
like if the crime is happening in a poor
neighborhood and it's not affecting
somebody's money
then nobody cares the second that crime
second they started breaking windows on
fifth avenue
now all of a sudden it's more now
about de blasio just says stand down let
them do it yeah
i mean let them burn themselves out we
did this in in the video but it was
really interesting because we had to
like
i had to like really process how i felt
about it because the looting obviously
was wrong and we did that clip on it but
like
the writing i understood and i think i
can justify
i was talking to this i don't know i
won't say his name because he's a
college professor i want to get him you
know in trouble for
talking to us and helping us out you
know a distinguished gentleman and we're
these ruffians but he was like
he's like you know really savvy with
constitutional law and stuff and he said
this argument i thought was really
interesting
when it comes to riots not looting
destruction of property is wrong and
you're doing it to benefit yourself when
you loot right you're right you're
taking advantage
of the tragedy right the tragedy is a
smoke screen so that you can benefit
right and um we made an interesting
distinction like any instagram model
that's also
taking a picture like at the thing but
not really actually doing anything it's
like you're looting too you're enriching
yourself you have one chick that
borrowed the guy's drill
to take it back that's the one that we
did and it was like that is that's
that's looting though like you're
enriching yourself off of tragedy that's
[ __ ] looting right yes
so peaceful protest is obviously great
looting wrong riding in the middle which
is destruction of property right
just like send this message and as mark
and i
we're putting together the piece we're
talking this dude he made this
interesting point he goes
as a citizen you have the right to you
know life liberty pursuit of happiness
but also property
right and if the state is destroying the
most valuable piece of property that you
have which is
your body right you have to take some
sort of recourse
in order to protect that right you've
broken they broke the social cons
contract they broke it right when they
maybe are shooting you or shooting your
neighbors etc
you peacefully protest if that goes on
deaf ears
for decades what the [ __ ] else are you
supposed to do
like what you can keep saying peacefully
protest but if it keeps on happening
there really isn't anything else
available to you
so the next thing is destruction of
property i
i i think the best way to do it probably
destroy public property not private
property
but if you destroy public property you'd
actually be taking the high road
because that's a response to having life
destroyed
you destroy my life i just [ __ ] up your
park who's reasonable here
well if it was all coordinated and
thought that way yes and i think what
happened in minnesota
in particular what happened with the
priests the police precinct right where
they burnt that [ __ ] thing down the
ground like
that was fascinating right it's when it
spreads across the country and then it
just becomes
two things it becomes peaceful protest
people mad at the cops yeah
and then looting and the looting is
different unacceptable but looting
unacceptable what's crazy is
along the way we get more
evidence of police brutality instead of
the cops saying hey
this guy killed this guy it makes us all
look terrible yeah we are not
like that we're better than that most of
them
probably did do that but a lot of them
they fell back to their cop ways
they fell back to their ways of smashing
[ __ ] shields into people
running over pedestrians all the crazy
[ __ ] that we saw
shooting a guy in the [ __ ] face with
a tear gas canister
you see that they pepper sprayed him and
then they shot him with a flashbang
right in the [ __ ] face
really oh my god it's crazy he's staying
alive he's get i think joe schilling has
that on his uh instagram page
there's a [ __ ] ins my friend joe
schilling was a kickboxer yeah
has he's been saying for the last six
seven days it's not one bad apple he
goes look at all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
cops that are doing [ __ ] so he's putting
video after video after video after
video after video
of cops grabbing a woman by the neck and
throwing her to the ground slamming
she's just
just like what are you saying to me why
why do i have to listen to you he's like
[ __ ] get on the ground
just grab amazing people mason young
girls
amazing people for no [ __ ] reason
yeah this one guy was
was talking [ __ ] to the cops so the cops
just walk right up to him
pepper spray him drag him throw him to
the ground you're taking away his
freedom of speech yeah the guy's not
committing a crime
you're violating the first amendment
you're violating his constitutional
rights you're breaking the social code
my friend joe has video after video
after video of this and i think one of
them i don't know if he has that in
there
but one of them is this dude gets pepper
sprayed in the face and then they
[ __ ]
splash i mean it hits him right off the
dome
it's crazy so many people got [ __ ] up
yeah my uh
my buddy is a uh he's a captain in the
marines right and uh
he was and he was in iraq and uh he goes
here's why i have no tolerance
whatsoever for police brutality
when we were in iraq the mission changed
and it went from go in there and [ __ ]
[ __ ] up that's how it is when you're
trying to win a war to win minds and
hearts
and they explain to us while we're there
we're winning minds and hearts and that
means you guys are gonna have to take on
more risk
that means you don't just kick in the
door and then light it up you have to
make sure that you're not taking
out innocence at least try
you are taking on more risk you are
risking your life so he goes when i see
police brutality i'm like
if we can afford that luxury to a
country that we're at war with
how the [ __ ] can we not afford that
luxury to our own citizens
he goes if i'm told to take on more risk
then maybe
these cops have to take on more risk and
pay them for it
increase payment increase training don't
defund
right but increase and increase the
requirements and really make them
heroes but he said this he was like it
seemed to me that the culture
at um of policing in america and i could
be wrong
i talked to cops about it but this what
he said it seems to me is
that the idea is no cop ever gets left
behind no cop ever goes down
instead of protecting people at all
costs right you know what i'm saying
mm-hmm i don't know i mean poke holes if
you
if you can no it it it makes sense well
i'm
fully in agreement that they need better
funding it needs to be a higher paying
job that's much more difficult to get
yep but when you see cops throw that old
man to the ground he bounces his [ __ ]
head off the ground you see the blood
come out of his head
no one does anything yep no one stops
them yeah no one
no one picks the guy up no one calls an
ambulance no one checks on him
yeah that you can't do that yeah that's
not serving that's not protecting
you just a guy said something you didn't
like so you threw him to the ground you
knew he was old and feeble you knew he
was
and you did it with potentially a
confidence
of knowing that nothing would happen to
you there wouldn't be any recourse and
that's that's when people go like uh
a bad apple ruins a bunch it's like no
it doesn't you just remove the bad apple
but if you can't remove the bad apple
right if there's systems in play that
don't allow it
then it ruins the bunch so if there's
one systemic change we make maybe it's
people get prosecuted or cops will get
prosecuted
for violating the law because i really
would allow
not allow i'd really love if we
had this relationship with the cops
we're like [ __ ] you guys are brave man
thank you
like [ __ ] because it is a [ __ ]
dangerous job yeah and thankless in a
lot of ways
a lot of ways so it's like why how do we
shift this and how much risk do they
have to take or what change do we make
so that we can look at them and go
thank god we got these guys around
because [ __ ] it's scary listen what you
said about your friend being the marines
it's [ __ ] hard to get through boot
camp man yeah it's hard
it's you're right there's a [ __ ] yeah
there's a there's a long
road that you have to travel to be a
navy seal right
that's how it should be to be a cop man
it should be [ __ ] hard to make it
and they should weed out the people that
are [ __ ] the people that are
sociopaths
the people that just would be willing to
lean their shin on a man's neck for
eight and a half minutes yeah those
people are sick
you gotta find those people before they
get to the position where they could do
that to a person and how do you do that
how do you get
your psych evals or yeah you got to
train them yeah
train them like they are the type of
people that
potentially could [ __ ] kill somebody
for the wrong reason
yeah you got to train them like you're
weeding them out like this is a great
honor
and we you know we can ship that but we
have to think about it in terms of
allocation of resources cops don't get
paid enough
teachers don't get paid enough either
though and they're not killing their
kids so i don't know but they [ __ ] them
they [ __ ] them sometimes and nobody goes
we should just stop school
right hey these teachers are [ __ ]
kids on the teachers
fun school teachers are blowing these
kids
this is [ __ ] crazy yeah dude i gotta
end this man
we've been doing it three and a half
hours oh jesus three hours three hours
we started a little later
all right well bro the deep state will
cut about it's great to see you i love
you
we don't see each other i know man but
it's always a good time um
hopefully next time we'll be doing
comedy i think it's going to be
something i can't wait what are you
going to be back here again
i don't know i'm going to do some shows
though i heard you're doing well i don't
want to mention but
i got some shows the grapevine i'm about
to pop off all right good
but um some [ __ ] might be going down in
ohio too chappelle's got some [ __ ] he's
playing
okay oh [ __ ] lots of things are
happening lots of things are happening
yeah so
my agent said that uh that you were
going around and i was like you know
what maybe i'll like
do something around your date i'll help
it man i'll promote it no
you don't have to what i'm saying is
like happen yeah like everybody could
just do each other's stuff and it would
just be like a fun
yes like we could reward the clubs that
are going let's open up i don't know
we'll talk about it off here well texas
texas is going guns blazing arizona
west states the ones that surprise the
ones that survived the [ __ ] wars with
the indians they're opening up data
right away disease don't kill us yes
andrew ladies and gentlemen love you
brother i love you too man thank you
you